Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile
before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism
living to show a medal.
This episode is brought to you by Peloton
and I'd heard about Peloton over and
over again, but I ended up getting
a Peloton bike in the whole system.
After I saw my buddy Kevin Rose, I've
known him forever, some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house
a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him as it, dude, you look great,
what the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing
a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean
after like 75 beers and he said,
I've been doing Peloton
five days a week now.
That caught my attention because Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know, I love you Kevin, but
it really peaked my curiosity,
ended up getting a system and it's
become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to
love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually,
but peloton is an indoor cycling bike
that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You don't have to worry about fitting
classes into your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of commute,
etc. New classes are added every day and
this includes options led by elite New
York City instructors
in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors or
find your own favorite
class on demand and in fact,
Kevin and I rarely do live classes
and you can compete with your friends,
which is also fun. Kevin,
I'm coming after you,
but we usually just use classes on demand.
I really like Matt [inaudible] and his
eye in high intensity training sessions
that are shorter,
like 20 minutes and I think
Kevin's favorite is Alex
and everyone seems to have
their favorite instructor or you can
select by music duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch
HD touchscreen performance tracking
metrics.
I think that that along with the realtime
leaderboard are the main reasons that
this caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller
than you would expect so it can fit in
a living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet,
believe it or not and
it fits with no problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer and it is actually special
visit one Peloton that's o n e p e l
o t o n one peloton.com and enter the
code Tim all caps Tim at checkout to
receive $100 off accessories
with your Peloton bike purchase.
You might say Matt accessories.
Wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever
other supplemental bits and pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and
those are in the accessory category.
So there's $100 off is
a very legit $100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really
entertaining way to do high intensity
interval training or anything else or
are you just want to get a fantastic gift
for someone,
check out Peloton one peloton.com
and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter
the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories including
the shoes that you all want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code Tim.
Yeah,
this episode is brought
to you by zip recruiter.
You may have heard them everywhere.
They're growing like crazy.
They're an innovative platform
for doing several things,
but especially improving
the hiring process,
making it slick and elegant and easy.
One of the hardest parts
of running any business,
growing any business is finding
and hiring the right team.
I've seen this firsthand in close
to a hundred startups. Now, God,
I'm getting old from all over the
world at different stages of growth and
nothing can quite drain your resources
and costs you time and money,
like making mistakes
in hiring ZipRecruiter,
develop their own system and their own
platform for helping you to solve two of
the biggest problems and
bottlenecks for employers,
posting jobs easily and then making it
even easier to find the best candidates.
Unlike other job sites,
zip recruiter does in effect the
opposite of what you'd expect.
So they do not depend on
candidates finding you there.
Technology finds the right
candidate for you and in fact,
more than 80% of the jobs posted on
ZipRecruiter returnee qualified candidate
based on your criteria that
you select in just 24 hours.
So no more juggling email, reviewing
hundreds of unqualified candidates.
I've been there,
done that.
Don't recommend it or dealing with calls
to the office, et Cetera. None of that.
Simply screen rate and manage
your candidates all in one
place on Ziprecruiter's
dashboard and as a listener
of the Tim Ferriss show.
Thanks for that zip recruiter wants
to allow you to start posting jobs and
trying their services for free,
so if you're thinking of hiring somebody,
you need to find any an executive
assistant, you need to find a developer,
whatever it might be tried up.
Just visit ziprecruiter.com forward
slash Tim and you can experience just how
zip recruiter has been used by businesses
of all different sizes to find the
most qualified job candidates.
Again,
that's ziprecruiter.com
forward slash Tim check it out,
give it a spin.
Hello,
boys and girls and demoss he caballeros.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class
performers of all different types to
tease out the tactics, habits,
routines and so on that you can use.
I am recording this intro and a Mexican
airport after a top secret retreat doing
top secret things, and maybe I'll
talk more about that sometime,
but this episode you're going to hear
is with one of my favorite people,
Tim O'reilly and I recorded this sometime
ago and held onto it like a piece of
gold to my chest to release at the
right time at Tim O'reilly on Twitter.
It's one of the most fascinating
polymaths and autodidacts,
one of the most curious
minds I've ever encountered.
He's been called the trend spotter in
the world of tech and certainly involving
wider macrotrends. He's been called
the oracle of Silicon Valley.
He is the founder and CEO
of O'reilly Media Inc.
His original business
plan was pretty simple,
interesting work for interesting people
and that's worked out pretty well.
He's generated hundreds of millions
of dollars in revenue at doing many,
many different things around the media,
delivers online learning, publishes books,
runs conferences or just companies to
create more value than they capture and
tries to change the world by spreading
and amplifying the knowledge of
innovators. But as he would say himself,
one of my favorite quotes of his,
sorry for the noise. This is some
audio verite for all of you guys,
but he would say quote money in
a business like gas in a car.
You don't want to run out, but you're
not doing a tour of gas stations.
And we talk quite a bit about that.
Tim has an incredible history of
convening conversations that reshape the
computer industry in
93 that's 1993 for you.
Youngins he launched the first commercial
website that was very Sean Connery,
the first commercial website.
And then in [inaudible] 98 he organized
the meeting where the term open source.
I've been speaking too much, Gus the
Yanno. My English is not happening.
Open source software. My
God, let's try that again.
He organized the meeting
where the term open source,
I swear to God, I'm not drunk
guys. Open source software.
It was agreed on and help the business
world understand its importance.
In 2004 with the web 2.0 summit.
He defined how web 2.0 represented not
only the resurgence of the web after
the.com bust, but entirely new model for
the computer industry based on big data,
collective intelligence and
the Internet as a platform.
Web 2.0 is actually one of the conferences
where the four hour workweek reached
it's tipping point,
so also thank you to Tim for that.
In 2009 with his Gov 2.0 summit,
he framed the conversation around the
modernization of government technology
that is shaped policy and spot
initiatives at the federal,
state and local level
and all around the world.
He has now turned his attention and is
very focused on artificial intelligence,
the implications,
artificial intelligence,
the on demand economy and
other technologies that are
transforming the nature of
work and the future shape
of the business world.
He really has a both a 30,000
foot view of the larger shifts,
the tectonic shifts that will
produce changes in 10, 20,
30 years but is also on the ground and
really in touch with the people who are
shaping the details of how that will
come to pass. And uh, his brand new book,
which I encourage everybody
to check out his WTF,
what's the future and why it's up to us.
And I will link to all of that in
the show notes of course. And if you,
if you'd like to Kevin Kelly,
he is a bird of a feather with
this fine jet, Tim O'Reilly.
So without further ado, please enjoy
this very wide ranging extremely for me.
Certainly enjoyable
conversation with Tim O'reilly.
Tim, welcome to the show. Thank you for
making the time. Thanks for having me.
I have been looking forward to this for
some time and most recently your name
came up because I was in a car in
the back mountains surrounding.
Part of it was Becca,
Stan with Kevin Kelly and our friend
Kevin Kelly on a very short list.
When I asked him, who do you think I
should absolutely have on the podcast?
Tim O'reilly was one of
the names that came up.
So I also leaned on Kevin for some,
some deep intel and suggested
topics and questions.
But I thought I would start
with what's on everyone's mind,
which is why are you
similar to cookie monster?
Yes. Well, I often joke about myself,
uh, you know, as a VC and
a business person, uh,
that I'm a little bit like the,
um,
some episode I remember for my kids
were little on cookie monster. I made,
I have this completely right,
but he's on a game show and
he has to pick his prize.
And behind door number one is $1 million
and they tell him that behind door
number two is a chateau in France.
And behind door number three is a cookie.
And of course everybody
knows what he picks. And,
and what I like to say about myself is
that I always go for the cookie. Uh,
you know, because in some sense,
you know, what I really care about,
what's my cookie is a finding people who
are doing something new and interesting
that I think other people want to know
about and that they can learn from.
And you know, my whole business
has been built around, you know,
finding people who have cookies
and then sharing it with the world.
So not,
not to take the cookie
monster discussion too far,
but you didn't know this.
I happened to be standing in a house
where seasons one through 10 of sesame
street.
We're partly written.
So many of the characters including cookie
monster were actually written where I
am standing. So it's coming back
amazing. So it's come full circle.
And when I bought the house,
they were going to throw everything out.
The former owners,
including a season one staff
jacket for sesame street,
which of course I kept and uh,
that is hanging in the doorway.
But when we come back to ideas and we'll
certainly spend a lot of time talking
about publishing in many things that
are perhaps a little more recent in your
life,
but I want to rewind the clock a bit
and to start maybe with an odd story.
Could you tell me about how your father,
who my understanding was in neurologist
also deeply religious injected
radioactive copper isotopes into your arm?
Is that a true story?
Has Absolutely.
Tell me I need some work on tax done.
It wasn't my dad who injected them. It
was a guy named Leroy Shipley. He was the,
the lab tech and Oh my God,
he was amazing. He was very
funny. But, uh, I was, uh,
my best friend that I, and my best
friend's sisters when I was 14 there,
the girls were a little
older, uh, agreed to, um,
participate in a study of
Wilson's disease, which was,
it is a disease of the abnormal
retention of copper in the body.
It's a genetic disease.
Um, my dad was a, you know,
sort of a pioneer in early genetic
medicine, also radio medicine and,
uh, Wilson's disease was
one of his specialties.
And so they needed to have
control subjects to understand
how copper is excreta
normally. And so they would
inject us with radioactive copper.
And then every day we went in and lay
in this room with, it was massive thing,
you know,
it wasn't like today's a Mris,
but it was just this whole room that was
called a whole body counter. And they,
they, they kind of traced where the copper
went accumulates in the liver, uh, in,
in, uh, and then in the brain
of people with Wilson's disease.
And it's normally excrete it, uh,
after, uh, about, uh, you know,
some relatively small amount of time.
So it was copper 64.
It's got a half life or a few weeks.
And so I presumably it was all gone.
Uh, but if I ever come down with liver
cancer, I may have my father to blame,
but we think we actually did
it twice. Uh, but, and again,
he obviously took some thought
about whether it was safe,
because once we became lab rats for him,
uh,
there were other researchers who wanted
us to do other experiments and he,
you know, said, no, I don't want you
to do that one. That doesn't seem,
seem right to me. So, uh, he of course,
used himself as a Guinea pig for, uh,
for, uh, his experiments.
What did your mother do? I mean,
you had, as I understand it,
let's see, seven children total in the
family. That's correct. What did your,
I mean, that's certainly a fulltime job
just to take care of the kids, but what,
what did your mom spend
her time doing primarily?
Uh, you know, I think taking
care of seven is huge.
I still remember her,
one of my memories of my mom is her on
her hands and knees in the bathroom,
scrubbing the toilet, and she looks up
and says, life is not a bowl of cherries
are. Of course, the idea
of my mom, uh, like,
that brings up another great story
about the time that she likes to tell.
Uh, she was apparently, uh, you know,
up on a piano stool trying to dust
a light. And she fell flat on that.
She fell off and it was lying flat
on the floor. And my brother, James,
he must've been eight or nine at the time,
came running in from the school yard.
We lived about a block from the school,
sees her on the floor and says, mommy,
what time is it? And she
says, James, I don't know.
And he goes, okay, and runs back
out. And then later she said,
what did you think I was
doing lying on the floor? And
he said, well, I don't know,
maybe it dusting under the piano.
So she was basically, uh, uh, she
was the old school, you know, I mean,
she made every bit, I mean, I
kind of went back and I go, shit,
I should've made us do more of the
work. You know, we had some chores,
but basically she made all the beds. She,
you know, you know, it was just, you know,
it's a lot with seven kids. And again, of
course, you know, the, the, uh, you know,
I was in the older cohorts, so there
were still, you know, young babies. Um,
you know, and I think, um,
the thing that's actually been been
such a great delight to me in my life,
my dad died very young, died
at 60, uh, you know, so, and,
and that's now, uh, you
know, 40 years back. Um,
and, uh, just, uh, my mom, uh, you
know, later came to travel with me.
She would just come with me on, on, uh, my
business trips. And she was just such a,
a willing, interested travel. She was,
she was a girl from the back of the mail
and Yorkshire, you know, kind of grew up,
uh, you know, uh, you know, from, uh, uh,
actually, you know, the, the, the, uh,
her parents and her grandparents
before that were factory workers,
but her dad was also a
bookie, uh, you know,
taking bets on horses back when
it was illegal. And so, uh,
she always would tell us stories,
which for her were full of shame.
But for us,
we're full of romance of how she used
to have to go collect Beth's from
strangers in the park when she was
a girl and the police would come,
he'd have to light out over the
back fence is, uh, we, we, we, we,
we took great delight in
the thought that, that, uh,
we were descended from petty
criminals. I mean, again,
of course by the time, you know, I was
a teenager and went to visit, uh, the,
it was legal and his son actually had
the bedding business and a little betting
shop. Um, but, uh, uh, it's,
uh, it's a lot of fun and it actually
brings up something that's completely
irrelevant, but kind of a bit of
pattern recognition. Uh, you know,
the fact that here was a guy who,
you know,
had a living doing something that was
illegal and then when it became legalized,
he was able to do it. And, uh, uh, it, um,
made me think of what's
happening right now with, um, uh,
you know, with weed in, in places like
California where it's been legalized.
And,
um,
mmm,
uh, sorry, I'm trying to think of the, the
head of the San Francisco Foundation, um,
was over at dinner and,
um, you know, we're, we're,
we're talking about various issues and,
and uh,
he says, uh, this is
Fred Blackwell. He says,
well, what about the weed problem? I
said, what do you mean the weed problem?
He says, well, you know,
there's all these people coming in now
and they're making all this money selling
weed.
And the only people who can't participate
in this new economy are all the black
and brown people who have convictions
on their record for selling weed.
You know, and, and, you know,
it's just that kind of interesting thing
that we don't think about. You know,
when we changed the rules,
what do we do about the people who,
you know,
played by the old rules,
the new rules.
And that just kind of leads me down the
path of a lot of what's broken and our
society is,
you know,
this sort of layering
of ideas that change,
but they change in completely,
uh, people have this, you know,
effectively bad map of the world.
It doesn't work anymore.
And uh, you know, same
kind of thing. Again,
a lot of the work that we do at code for
America, my wife's nonprofit is around,
you know, fixing some of these things.
Yeah. We do a lot of work and a expunging,
you know, low level, you
know, uh, offenses. That's
why we were talking with Fred.
Um, you know, from people's record,
they pass something called prop 47 here
in California and there was something
like 30, $40 million spent
to pass this proposition.
But the implementation,
nobody thought about it.
And so a tiny fraction of the people
who are eligible have actually done it.
And the same thing we saw with
the healthcare.gov failure
back in 2013, you know,
people pass policies and
they don't actually think
about how are we going to do
it? How are we going to actually
do this thing? You know,
so right now if you want to clear your
record, you have to go get your, you know,
go to the DA's office and you pick up
this form and then you go somewhere else
and get it signed by someone.
And you know,
these are people who don't
have the time to go, you know,
spend months on this process. You
know, if they were going to pass this,
you know,
they could have thought through how are
we going to make this easier for people.
And a lot of the work that we do,
the other work we do things like a
w we work on improving access to um,
you know, food aid. And
we got brought in, uh,
because they didn't really understand
why people were signing up and then
falling off the program and then
signing up again immediately.
And it was just administrative stuff that
people didn't know how to comply with
and they didn't have any measurement.
You know, in the tech world, you know,
people have gotten very used to ab
testing and measuring things and
understanding, oh, this, this is,
this is where people are
falling out of our pipeline.
This is where things don't work.
And a lot of what we've ended up building
at code for America are our alternate
pathways that are designed to
teach us about what's wrong.
You know, so we're, we're, we're
sort of their exploratory, a Jen,
my wife Jen Pahlka calls it apps to ops.
You know,
we're basically building
apps that actually do let us
follow the users so we can
say, Oh, you know,
here you are losing some number of
people because your application takes 45
minutes to fill out.
And there are people who are trying to
do this in libraries where there is a 30
minute timeout and you have no mechanism
for them to save their work. You know,
stuff like that. Or, you
know, hey, you know, uh,
you're telling people their documents are
uploaded successfully, but they're not,
you know, or you're sending
out, uh, uh, you know,
in some counties they were
sending out, uh, you know,
letters about people's appointments
that they were hers to make.
And they would come in,
uh,
they would come out 25% of them
or some significant fraction.
We come out after the date of the
appointment and they didn't know it.
That was the worst part. Not It was
bad enough that it was happening,
but they didn't know it at the same thing.
True. You know, we, we work, uh, uh,
you know, a lot with at the federal
level, under Obama, uh, generous, uh,
deputy CTO and help set up something
called the United States digital service.
And, you know, a lot of the problems
at the Va were very similar.
People would be applying, uh,
from library computers, you know,
homeless vets and they couldn't get
through the process. And, you know,
basically the people in Washington w,
you know, the Va headquarters for saying,
well, they're obviously not
eligible because they're not
succeeding. And you know,
they had tested and you know,
the, the, the, the procurement
process meant, oh yeah,
we have to test this APP.
But they tested it with a particular
combination of Internet explorer and Adobe
software.
And that wasn't what was out there
in the real world and it didn't work.
And so they went out and just film the
users and then they were able to go see,
look,
it really doesn't work.
And in some ways that's been my life.
You know,
it's funny because code for is that
have a latest incarnation or one of the
latest incarnations of that. But when
I was early in my career, you know,
it was just like, oh, this is not, you
know, doing documentation, you know,
writing down the steps.
I still remember working with one author
on one of our early books and he said,
I can't write this chapter yet. And I
said, that's what he said. I said, why?
And he said, because the software
doesn't work. And I said,
that's what you have to write because
you know, while you're sitting here
not getting this book done and this,
this piece of the,
of the software that doesn't work,
people are beating their heads against
the wall and they think it's them
telling them that it doesn't work is
actually the documentation that's needed
right now.
Uh,
so I want to underscore something,
see this question of how can we make
x easier for people or why isn't,
why easier for people? And I do want
to rewind just a little bit because I,
and many people are very interested in
how you think and how that leads to,
for instance, identifying edges. I mean,
you've been a great pioneer on the
edge of many different frontiers.
So I want to go back to
not necessarily the bookie,
but to,
to ask what,
well, first of all, this
is just personal curiosity.
What do your other siblings do these
days as professions or any examples?
Well, let me kind of
go through my, um, uh,
my oldest brother,
uh,
has had a pastiche of careers.
He owns a small fleet of taxi cabs where
he's been competing with, uh, with, uh,
with, uh, Uber and Lyft
and, and, you know,
kind of fulminating against
the taxi system. He, you know,
he would like to be able to operate like
Uber and Lyft and can't, you know, and,
and, uh, um, uh, he also runs a,
a a business reselling used books,
including mine on Amazon.
So he's kind of in these, and
unfortunately he's dealing
with two very, uh, uh,
declining industries. Uh, and, uh, he, um,
uh, uh, my,
my next brother as run a small publishing
company that I started with him called
travelers tales,
which a row basically was a
story based approach to travel,
you know, rather than guide books,
which tell you, uh, in a what to do.
It was like more like people sharing
their experiences so you can go, oh, yeah,
that sounds like exactly what I want
as opposed to kind of like the catalog
approach. And, uh, uh, so he's big,
been a travel writer for many years.
And then, uh, my, uh, all of my sisters,
uh, have basically, uh, just,
uh, have raised families. Uh,
although it's interesting, a very
heavy percentage of homeschooling in,
in my family. And, uh, so that's,
so they've been teachers as well as,
as a, uh, as parents. My younger brother,
frank is a builder, a in ecology,
be basically built, um, uh,
uh, a house to live in and a, and never
looked back. You know, it was like,
they went, I think it was a junior, he
had a friend built the house that they,
they went and lived in and then
they weren't, this was great.
So they rented it to some other
students, uh, the, uh, uh,
and then built one over the summer
and lived in that and then, you
know, anyway, so he started, uh,
and it's kind of funny because
he's really built the hope.
He still lives near the college he lived
in and he's built, you know, the church,
the school, the library,
you know, the, uh,
the home is that many of the people
live in. And he now has a, you know,
kind of a business that's
a rental businesses,
some actually fabulous places he's built
on the Shenandoah river that, uh, uh,
he ran since kind of interesting because
he's actually been a lot like me and
that he built his business
just intuitively from the
ground up by following his
nose. And what was so interesting
though, when we were growing up,
if you had asked my mom,
she would have said that frank
and I were the most dissimilar.
Why is that? Well, because, you know,
I was always the top student
in school and he was, you know,
he got D's And F's and you know,
and we were with my brothers
and I were always say, no, no,
he just isn't interested in it because
we would see him at home. You know,
when he was 10 years old,
he,
he got totally obsessed with the civil
war and he'd read it was reading Bruce
Cat and then all the history, you know, he
did a lot, lots and lots of history and,
you know,
and,
and setting up these enormous
recreation's of battles of the civil war.
And we were, he's just not
interested in school. And, uh,
you know, I, and, and so, you
know, just sort of interesting
watching. He's, you know,
he's, he's, uh, seven
years younger than I am,
but watching him kind of have the same
path of building his own business, uh,
you know, creating a lot of value
for the people around him, uh,
uh, and, and, and pivoting as necessary.
You know, he, he got into the, the, uh,
even though he started with this sort
of rental thing in college to be,
it was basically building
and selling homes. Uh,
and then after the 2008 financial crisis,
nobody would finance, uh, you
know, homes unless you had cash.
So he basically, but you could borrow
for a business property. So he ended up,
you know,
building,
he had these lots and started building
places then renting them and he actually
got pretty good at it. So he, he,
uh, you know, he is a variety of,
of businesses and a [inaudible].
What,
what advice would you give to a
parent who has a kid currently,
like your brother who's clearly very,
very bright but just doesn't seem to be
interested in school and therefore is
getting poor grades?
What would you,
what would you say to someone
like that parent in that position?
It's a,
it's a,
it's sort of a tough one because
sometimes you do have to push kids.
I think the main thing,
and this is true,
whether you're a parent with your
kids or whether you're, uh, you know,
a business person or just somebody trying
to solve problems in your own life is
having an attitude of receptivity and
openness and looking really looking and
understanding what's going on. I mean,
you know, at the end of the day, uh,
there are no recipes and
so many problems come from,
you know,
people following recipes or following
maps that don't match the reality.
And you know, like frank didn't
match the, the, you know,
the recipe of what you were supposed to
do in school, but it was pretty clear.
He w he was following his own path.
Same thing's true, uh, of, uh,
you know, I have two daughters
and one of them school was easy.
She always did well. The other
one, you know, not so well,
but she was like totally
following her own path.
And she's become this
amazing sound artists,
these artists and residents
of the exploratorium, uh, you
know, created a, you know,
uh, uh, you know,
an iPhone app for something called
rhythm necklace is this different way of
visualizing, know rhythm. Uh, she's
sort of exploring medieval hocket and,
and she's, you know, scored stuff for, uh,
you know, Bjorks biophilia tour and, uh,
you know, created a, you know,
the sort of all these sort
of odd musical instruments.
Just totally built her own curiosity
driven pass into the world.
And, and uh, you know, so the, the,
the thing I guess I would just say
is like, look at your kid. You know,
there's a wonderful book, I
forget the name of the author. Um,
it's called loving every child.
Uh, and it's about a guy,
uh, in Nazi Germany. Uh, he,
he basically had two
schools and, um, one was,
you know, for, uh, children of,
you know, so wealthy, you know,
Germans, uh, you know, and then the
other was a segregated school for Jews.
And when they came to
take his Jewish kids,
he went with them and died in
the concentration camp. And,
uh, sorry, um,
uh,
funny how we can forget those things.
Uh, but anyway, but it does, the
point of the book is, is, you know,
if I love your children, look
at them, understand them,
and listen to them. And, and,
uh, the thing that I think,
you know, the, you know,
treat them as people. I mean,
a lot of people treat their
kids as objects. You know,
I've been in a room with people where
they talk about their kids when they're
there, as if they don't, you know, they
don't listen. They're not there, you know,
or they just, um, you know, as
the kids are on show or they're,
uh, you know, told what to
do and, and yeah. You know,
it's like treat them like you
would want to be treated. You know,
I guess I felt like I did my
best, you know, as a parent,
parenting is a hard job,
you know,
to just be there with
your kids and, and, uh,
talk with them and listen to them.
What,
are there any questions that you'd like
to ask your kids a lot.
Are there any uh,
or questions that you've
taught them to ask themselves?
This might seem like a non sequitur,
but
it's what came to mind for me.
So good. I, you know, uh, I, I wish I
had an easy answer to it and I don't,
um,
that's okay. I don't have kids. I
don't have any answers to it. Yeah.
Well, the one thing that I, I, this
is not a question, but that, you know,
there's one piece of life advice
that I give in the form of a quote.
It's almost like a psychiatrist named
urban yellow, who is also a novelist.
And he wrote a novel called when
nature wept, uh, which is, uh,
an imagined, um, uh,
the story of early psychoanalyst,
a analysis. Actually Pre Freud,
there was a guy who was a predecessor to
Freud and it's, it's basically him, uh,
analyzing nature.
There's this one line in it that really
stuck in my head as lions do sometimes
from books. And it was, um, uh,
first we'll what is necessary
and then log what you will.
And you know,
it,
it does have to do with the one thing
that I think we do have to teach our
children. Oh Wow. There's a lot of
things we have to teach our children.
But one of them is that
everything doesn't come easily.
And there are some things that you
have to do that you don't want to do.
And one of the secrets of
success in life is to first,
you know, we'll those things
and then come to love them.
And you think about that with exercise,
the great example, you know what I mean?
Once you know, it's like,
it's, it's hard to get started,
but once you get in into it,
it becomes a joy. And, uh,
there are a lot of things that are
like that, you know, doing the dishes,
cleaning the house, uh, you know,
looking after other people and,
and so,
you know,
sort of understanding how
having an understanding of,
of what your responsibilities are and
then working at them if necessary with
will until they become something that
you love is just an incredibly useful
piece of life advice.
So I'm definitely going to want to
come back and talk about what you've,
what you have personally found
difficult or difficult moments,
but I want to ask about
a decision that you made.
And this is transitioning
from a classics degree,
uh, to writing technical manuals, uh,
for lack of a better descriptor. You
could certainly give some more context,
but how did that happen
and why did you decide to
trend in that direction? Well, it, it,
it was pretty simple. First of all,
let me give a little context
for the classics. Um,
I had worked in the early seventies
when I was actually just even a teenager
with a guy named George Simon who,
uh,
had developed this theory about the
evolution of consciousness and also about,
uh, sort of a, a sort of an
experiential approach to, um,
you know, kind of inner
spiritual growth. You know,
I could kind of go into it in
more detail, um, but let me just,
and, but one of his ideas was that the
had been this profound evolution of
consciousness over time.
Uh,
and then there was a sort of a historical
art to it and that we were in a period
of a sort of individuation that had
really begun in classical Greece.
Um, and yeah, you know, there are
actually books like grittiness, Nell's,
the discovery of the mind where
you can kind of see this, you know,
that when they talk about,
you know, in home or, uh,
you know, uh, [inaudible], uh,
doesn't decide to do something.
You know, Athena puts this idea
into his two mosques, his liver,
and he acts. And then by the time,
you know, 400 years later, you know,
you know,
when you're reading about Socrates,
you're seeing them wrestling with these
ideas that really are at the heart of,
you know, what is truth? What is justice?
What is, you know, uh, you know, uh,
what is happiness? And, uh,
but that was sort of the subject of my
thesis in classics was really about,
uh, it was about mysticism
and logic and in Plato of,
because they would kind of talk about,
well, you know, these mystical passages,
he must've been influenced by the
orthotics. And I'm like, no, you know,
these things that we now kind of
rehearse, you know, like ideas of justice.
They were incredibly new and powerful
and yes, they felt like, uh, you know,
these mystical kind of things that
they were wrestling with. And, and, uh,
but anyway, but I digress. But,
so the point of the reason
I was interested in classics
was deeply connected
with George's theory because I was into
like, okay, we're now entering into,
he had this idea that we were
entering into this new phase of global
consciousness. And as a real irony,
because my long detour into tech,
uh, was, uh,
it turned out not to be a detour at all
because who would have thought that,
you know, uh, you know, I'm trying to
think how much longer, 30 years later,
I would be kind of the profit of global
consciousness in the form of web today
and mediated by technology. But to
answer your question very specifically,
uh, it was, you know, uh, my,
my wife and I have been talking about
having kids. She was saying, you know,
I have about six, she was seven
years old and I, I wasn't,
she was ready before I was
and I was 24 and I basically
said, you know, one day I said,
I'm ready. You know, she had
been saying what some kids,
and I said, okay, I'm ready.
And, and the very next day, uh,
I still remember it, you know,
these three things happen on the same
day and it was almost like a sign.
One of them. Uh, well I guess the, the,
the main thing I would just say is
once I decided it was sort of like, oh,
I have to start really being the
breadwinner, I have to be a provider.
And it was sort of like a, a light gun,
you know, switch got flicked, you know,
it was like, wow, daddy juice kicked
in. And uh, you know, I had been,
uh, so I, uh, the,
the three things that happen the day
of that decision or the day after that
decision, one, it was, it was not
really meaningful other than, uh,
just a psychological boost.
Uh,
I had a friend who was dating the
Philippine ambassador to the UN and he was
trying to remember a quote from loud and
she knew that I was really deeply into
Lao Tzu. And uh, so yeah,
she called me up to say, Hey,
my aunt and my friend needs this quote
free speech. He's going to give it to you,
ed. You could, you could, you know, it
was, and it was just kind of cool air.
I am as you know,
this kid being asked
as a source for this speech that gave
me a boost. The other thing was, uh,
I got approached by another friend
to write a book about Frank Herbert,
which is the scent.
And the thing that ended up convincing
me that I was a writer. And then, uh,
the third thing was I had this friend
who was a programmer who got asked to
write a manual and I
said I would help him.
And so in some ways it was a,
you know,
like I made the decision
and then magically, uh, the,
all the pieces arrived on the table,
you know,
for me to start assembling
the puzzle of my life
or I need perhaps you also, I just
had the selective attention. Yeah.
To spot those things.
I've had a couple of questions
I don't want to gloss over this.
One day I woke up and I
said, I am ready. Yeah.
What triggered that?
It was there a conversation you had in
your head over that cup of coffee that
morning?
Was there a realization what,
what actually led you to
proclaim that you are ready?
Let me kind of go back to George Simon
because a lot of what he taught was a
kind of a,
a kind of mental discipline.
And that was rooted in a model
of how consciousness happens.
And it was, uh, it was sort of
framed somewhat in the language of,
of uh, Alfred Korzybski
is general semantics. Uh,
cause he had this wonderful
diagram that he drew.
It was actually a tool that
he used to train people.
He called the structural differential.
And of course Lipsky's fundamental
idea was that people are
stuck in language,
but language is about something.
And so he represented the process of
what he called the process of abstraction
so that people could kind of ask
themselves, where are you in that process?
And so the structural differential
ha, the first part was a parabola. Uh,
you know,
and the idea was the reason why it's a
parabola is because reality is infinite,
but we can't take in all of reality.
And so hanging from the
parabola was a circle.
And the circle was our experience,
which is our first
abstraction from reality.
And then hanging from the
circle are a bunch of, you know,
a label shaped tags,
like multiple strings of them.
And these are the words that we
use to describe our experience.
And Chris Sinski's training was for
people to recognize when they were in the
words, when they were in the experience,
when they were open to the reality.
And George kind of mix
that in with, uh, this, uh,
work of, of, uh, Sri Aurobindo
who was, uh, you know, uh,
Indian sage and kind of had come up
with a model that kind of an integrated,
kind of a spiritual view of this m
and a practice, which was a kind of,
of just listening, you know,
being open to the unknown.
Is that an active, is that,
yes, it's a tactic thing. You
know, you, you, you, you know,
it's just like, uh, you can
see when somebody is doing it,
but it's just like letting go,
letting things come in.
Yeah.
And then actually letting,
if you do it correctly,
what starts to happen is you start feeling
things and you don't really know what
they are. They don't match. You
know, it's not like, you know, you,
you put your hand on a table
and you feel the table,
but there's kind of a spiritual energy
that you feel and you sit with it and
eventually ideas for him.
You'll see this actual process
that was described by the, the,
the structural differential you can
actually use as a spiritual practice and
you're wrestling with a problem.
Like, am I ready to have kids?
You're not sitting there down
in the labels saying, you know,
pros and cons, you know, there
are people who do that, right?
But using this approach,
you simply say,
you know, uh, you know,
let me pose this as a problem to this
infinite universe and let me sit in an
attitude of receptivity and
listen to one answer counts.
And I think this is what a lot of
people mean by prayer. Uh, but,
but it's really interesting to put it in
the context of perception because this
same process happens in the
real world. You know, it, it
is what happens. You know,
there's these things outside you
and you don't really look at them
and no, you don't take them in and then,
you know, but so there's sort of this,
so basically the answer is I kind of said,
am I ready?
I just had this attitude
of openness and this,
this internal process that goes on.
And then one day it just crystallizes
and the label that hangs off that moment,
the first label is, I'm ready, you know?
And then the next label is,
uh, you know, here are these,
these things that I'm going to do.
Yeah.
So I am fascinated by this. The,
did you pose the question then?
I have a number of
friends, uh, Josh Waitzkin,
who's best known as the inspiration for
the book and the movie searching for
Bobby Fischer,
who's thought of as a chess prodigy.
But there's a lot more than that.
Reid Hoffman also as a similar approach
to journaling where they will pose a
question to themselves,
the day or the night prior to when
they journal in the morning for you.
Did you pose this question
at a particular time when,
uh, and you know, maybe
there are, is this,
is this something that you
have used in other places?
Oh, absolutely. I mean, you know, for me,
I mean at that particular time, you know,
when I was younger and closer to that as,
you know, a big part of my daily work,
uh, I think it was just sort
of a natural outflow. I mean,
at the time what I was doing for a living
was actually teaching these techniques.
So it was sort of, you know, I
lived and breathed this stuff. Um,
and, but, but it's, it's,
it's continued to be
this key part of my life.
Whenever I'm confronted with a problem,
you know,
you find yourself wrestling and you go,
oh wait, I'm just rearranging the labels.
Could you give me a useful,
could you give me a real world
example from your life? Um,
or a hypothetical? Uh, but yeah.
Well let me, let me give
you a very, you know, um,
a specific business example. It's not
quite the same in the end that it wasn't,
um, you know, kind of
this explicitly enter
process, but it was certainly
an outgrowth. Oh, it actually,
it wasn't an or process. I
take it back. Uh, so I had,
and this is my sort of my contribution
to the evolution of the open source
movement.
So I was sitting there and I had been
part of this Unix community and this
Internet community and I noticed
something and what I noticed was that the
people, for the most part, the
people that I knew from Unix,
which is really represented by people
who are around this community of this
conference called use next.
And then the people from the Internet
who were kind of would meet over the IATF
with relatively few exceptions,
didn't overlap. Right.
And then they did overlap with my life
because I was publishing books about,
you know, both work coming out
of both of these communities.
And I thought,
I want to bring them together,
but something was
stopping me. You know, like
I had this idea, I wanted to,
uh, you know, get people
from the community.
And I started thinking about it and I
kept delaying and delaying and delaying
and it was like there was something,
um,
that was not letting me do it.
And then one, you know, and I was,
I was at one and then Netscape
announced that they were going to,
to release, uh, what later
became Mozilla as free software.
I went, Damn, I'm too late. You know,
I've, I've done this, I should, you know,
kind of moved on this sooner. It's now
starting to become a story about it,
a free software and why it's
important. And, and, uh,
and,
and then I got kicked me into gear and I
organize this event that I first called
the free,
where summit,
where I invited in people from all
of these different communities.
And it was at that meeting that, uh,
Eric Raymond said, well, you know,
we were meeting a couple of weeks ago
and Christine Peterson came up with this
new name open source software because
you know, free software has these,
these problems, uh, you
know, as, as a, as a name.
And we voted on it and they all agreed
to use, you know, free software has,
uh, that, yeah, I mean, open source
software as this name. And we,
I had organized a press conference at
the end of the day even though I didn't
know what the outcome was going
to be and we kind of, you know,
I put people up on this stage and said,
look at all these guys,
they all have dominant market share in
these interesting categories of software
and they all have this thing in common.
They give their software away for free.
Uh, you know, and we've come together
and we've decided on a new name for it.
We're calling it open source software.
And the thing that was sort of interesting
about that was first of all, yes,
I noticed that something was
wrong in the map of the world.
You know, that basically people who
were talking about free software,
we're only talking about Linux and it was
his whole other world of free software
over on the Internet side that was
left out because the dialogue was,
you know, about, you know, the battle
against Microsoft and the PC and so on.
And so I just kind of, you know, so I
was just sitting with it, you know, and,
and,
and trying to think about what to do
and that sitting and the attitude of
receptivity, it was something very similar
that kind of happened in some sense.
One day, you know, this thing happened.
It was I something that uses the analogy
of you're doing a puzzle and you can't
solve it. And then somebody
dumps new pieces on the
table, right? And then you go,
oh, there that one go, it fits right in.
And that's exactly what happened there.
But that waiting,
that waiting is this psych part of
the psychological process. You know,
like if you're sort of simple, if you kind
of have this engineering mindset, well,
we're just going to go and work with
all the pieces that we have, you know,
you may not get to the right
answer. And, and, and so this,
this receptivity to the unknown,
you know,
and I actually often think of
soccer thieves in this regard.
He referred to something, he
called these diamonds, you know,
just like listening to this inner
voice that would tell him yes or no.
And I also think there's this great
line that recurs a continually,
and my favorite translation and loud Su,
uh,
the way of life according to law suit
by Winter Benner and as the line is,
he has his no,
and he has his yes.
And listening to that no. And
that, yes. So, uh, you know,
I had this know about,
I'm not ready to have a child.
And then one day I had a yes,
and I had this,
no, I'm not ready to bring
all these people together.
And then I had a yes.
And the fact that that there's this,
yeah,
like I had no way of knowing that
this new term had been introduced,
but if I had had my
meeting a month earlier,
the term open source software would not
have been there to be picked up at my
meeting.
Hmm.
You know, and you, you can't, you can't
miss a mystery. Why is it that, you know,
like,
I didn't know that,
but some things stopped me and
I was kind of kicking myself,
but like listening to that inner
voice that just said, oh, I'm not,
and then one day it's like,
yes,
know he has his note and then he
has his yes. Or she has her. Yes.
So I, I think that you, and I might,
I don't know if you drink alcohol,
but if you do,
then maybe this is more of a
conversation for several bottles of wine.
But I do love what I'm about to bring up.
So you mentioned a deceased,
Aka Ulysses and the sort of, uh, uh,
God planting an idea or
desire in his liver. Right.
And then you have a flash forward to,
I think you had mentioned Plato and
grappling with this concept of justice and
then you know, what seemed to
mystical now being part of the norm.
Is our consciousness evolving or uh,
looking back at the framework that you
were discussing with the parabola then
abstraction.
So we have reality than it abstraction
of experience and a further abstraction
of language.
Are we just getting further from
reality or are they the same thing?
Evolving consciousness and getting
further from that direct experience of
greater reality?
Well,
you know, I think it's different.
I mean, when you say we,
if you mean all of humanity,
I think we're all uh,
know rediscovering,
you know,
that process in our
lives. You know, um, I,
I think, uh, societies can
get further or closer, uh,
individuals can get further or closer,
but I think as a whole we have in fact
taken in more and more of that parabola.
You know, the, the, the circle has
gotten bigger and the, the, the,
the useful, you know, labels have gotten
bigger. Also, many of them have gotten,
you know, things would get
mislabeled. But I, you know,
if you think I, and this was sort of
another piece of what I learned from,
from George Simon, and it really
was this idea that that is our work.
Our work is to take in more of the unknown
and to bring it into our experience
and to bring it into our knowledge.
And there's always more, you know,
George used to have this
great formulation, he
referred to God as et Cetera,
all the rest.
I love it.
Yeah. And I love that it, you know,
and it's just sort of, for me, it's,
it's a useful,
not just mental construct,
but psychological construct, you know, and
it comes up for me, you know, the way I,
the way I, you know, when I have an idea
like this, I just see it everywhere.
You know, it used to be this, I mean,
it still is, I think this, this, um,
mock Tarot deck called Morgan's
Taro. I've never seen, it was just,
it was popular in the 70s. I don't
know if it's still available anywhere,
but it had these, these,
uh, fabulous cards.
And my favorite card was always the one,
it was basically a blank card with
the caption. Always remember this,
always remember,
you know,
and it was just that moment of
just listening to the silence.
And, um, you know, when you have that
ability to listen to the silence,
you also have the
ability to, uh, you know,
take things in a different way
and see the world fresh. So,
so that I think about Morgan's
through. But I also think about, uh,
about a Wallace Stevens, my, one of
my favorite poets, uh, you know, uh,
an ordinary evening in new haven.
We keep coming back and back to the rail,
to the hotels and not to the hymns that
fall on it, out of the wind. Uh, you know,
uh, uh, you know, reality
is the beginning, not the
end that the naked Alpha,
not the higher infant and mega,
you know,
he's kind of talking about the way that
our mind endlessly elaborates on what he
calls the eyes of the eyes,
plane,
something vulgar of
experience. Um, you know,
and it has all the great line, you know,
um, a poem is the cry of it's occasion,
a part of the thing and not about it.
You know,
this dialogue between the mind and the
stuff that we engage with in the world,
you know,
is our life.
Uh, there's so many
directions we could go. Uh, I,
well, I'm going to tie
this into a later question,
but I wanted to flash
back to Frank Herbert.
You mentioned the name
and in, in passing, uh,
you wrote, as you mentioned, you as
an opportunity to write a biography.
It's correct me if I'm wrong,
but a Frank Herbert who is
the author of the Dune series,
Dune is
one of those fiction books,
the first UN that shaped a lot of how
I look at the world in some pretty,
uh, wide reaching ways. Uh,
why did you decide to undertake that?
Were there any lessons that you took
away from studying his life or his work?
I, you know, again, it was
a complete serendipity.
When my friend Dick Riley asked
me, yeah, when I write this book,
he had been appointed the editor
of this new series of, you know,
critical monographs, detective novelist
and science fiction novelist. Uh,
uh, you know, I first said, oh,
I wanted to write about Samuel
Delaney who was at the time,
my favorite writer because I had a,
I love the little book of
his called Empire Star,
which was as you might expect about
the nature of consciousness. And, and,
and Dick was one said, no, no, no,
I think a book on herb, you know,
we'll do much better. You should really
do, do, do. And I had loved doing, well,
I have a very funny story about it going
back to my childhood when I think I
read it when I was 12 and I
got it from the library on.
And I remember my dad picked me up
from the lake or said library in San
Francisco. And I was
used to get, you know,
you could check out eight
books and they'll get eight,
you know, big books. And,
you know,
he looks at this and he says it's sinful.
So larger books should be
devoted to science fiction.
So I couldn't quite bring myself when I
wrote the Frag herb book to dedicate it
to my father with that.
Right.
Ah,
eh. Uh, but, uh, anyway, but, but yeah,
I was really grateful to Dick Because,
uh, you know, I do, I can't, I mean,
I had loved doing, but getting deeper
into it and spending time with frank,
you know, it was definitely
one of the, you know, he was,
he was the other, you know,
I've had multiple fathers in my life,
which is a wonderful thing. You know,
people who've kind of helped shape me,
you know,
and it does make me think that one of
the things that you know is so missing in
our culture is that we
don't have enough fathers,
mothers, you know, sort of like
when, when you think about, you know,
how we were meant to be
raised, you know, in,
in these communities, you know, the, uh,
you know, the, the, the sort of,
the nuclear family is kind
of a crime against humanity.
That's a strong word, but just like,
how do we build stronger communities?
Because I think in my life,
you know,
how important it was to have people
who said, you're special, you know,
and I know you deeply and I see something
in you. And just to expect that, like,
you know, to adult parents and the only
people who can do that for you. Yeah.
How do we build richer communities of
adults who help model and shape our
children?
So I was just super lucky because I had
my own dad and I had George Simon and
then it had frank Herbert
and I had, yeah, my, uh,
my ex wife's father Jack,
the guy named Jack Feldman,
who kind of inspired me to
think about business. And yeah,
it was just so interested as I built
my business. You know, when he died,
it was almost like I had been leaning
on this wind and I almost fell over,
you know,
because it was,
it was just like I hadn't realized just
how much is continued to interest was
feeding me, you know, it's
like, Eh, and uh, you know, the,
the love and interest we can give
to other people is such a gift.
Did you spend,
and I apologize that I don't know this,
but I suppose it'd be boring if I knew
all the answers to my questions for this.
Uh, did you spend time with
Frank Herbert or was it
oh yeah, I did. I did. You
know, I the, um, and it was,
it was,
it was funny because I met with him
two or three times when I was writing.
I did two books. The first book was
this, uh, you know, critical biography.
And it was just really about his
books as much as about his life. Um,
and it only went up through,
uh, uh, doing messiah. You know,
none of the later doing books
had been written and that point,
which is fortunate because they
were just basically, you know,
he was kind of milking the
milking the golden franchises,
whereas the first three books were
really conceived of as a whole from the
beginning. Uh, but, uh, and
then the second book was a
collection of his essays.
So I, I basically, which I, you know,
I edited it and an interview,
so I interviewed him on the road for
the first book. He would, you know,
be at some science fiction
convention and so on.
So I interviewed him two or three times,
I think in that period.
Then what was sort of frustrating was I
wanted to get below the surface. He was,
he was sort of like, he was a brilliant
conversation list and he kind of would,
you know,
just very inspiring ideas about how
we have to live on the edge of crisis.
And it's what keeps us alive.
And you know, it just, you know,
it was just a fount of fascinating
ideas and, uh, you know,
so it was scintillating stuff that,
you know,
if you could do a do these
interviews, they, you know,
you could publish them immediately,
you know,
but I kind of wanted to get under the
surface and learn more about who he was
and how he thought and,
but I couldn't because he was sort of on,
cause he was on tour. Right. And then when
I did the second book where I was like,
I need some more of these sort
of frank on fire interviews.
I went through it.
He
was home in Port Townsend, Washington.
I know we hung out for a couple of days.
And uh,
yeah,
he was just mellow and relaxed and I
kind of learned all I got to know him and
you know, but it wasn't all this great
material and it was sort of like,
I got the interviews in the wrong
order. So anyway, but he was a,
he was a really wonderful
guy, uh, who, you know,
thought very deeply about the world,
had very prescient ideas about
the things that, uh, you know,
continue to bedevil us today. I think
of many great lines, you know, uh,
um,
from his books all the time.
Fear, fear is the mind killer. Yes.
And the desert and there's
so many good lines.
If you were to,
so I was a nonfiction purist for a very,
very long time, for decades. I'm
embarrassed in retrospect to admit this,
but I was of the mind for a very long
time that if I wanted to make stuff up,
I could do that in my own head.
And I want it to actually learn things.
By reading nonfiction, I've
realized how, at least for me,
how off that was and how many deep
truths are better transmitted through
fiction,
uh,
for nonfiction addicts who are willing
to have an intervention and read a few
fiction books.
Are there any that you would suggest
that you might suggest people start with,
Ooh,
that's so tough.
Or to make it less pressured
a few of your favorites?
Well, look this certain way, uh, you know,
books that have sort of shaped my life.
I mean, doing definitely one of them.
Uh, I highly recommend that,
uh, is, uh, another, uh,
fantasy book. I always not really
fantasy in the sense of, you know,
heroic fantasy that people think it is
a book called Islandia, uh, written. Uh,
it was actually a personal passion
project of a Boston lawyer named Austin
tapping. Right. Uh, it was just
an imaginary world. Uh, it was,
it was probably the closest analog
in the real world is New Zealand.
Uh,
you know,
was this pastoral country somewhere in
the southern hemisphere that had been
closed off to Western civilization. The
guy started writing it in like 19, 10,
and uh, uh, he died in a
car accident in 1930 or so,
and in the mid forties,
43, I think it was,
his daughter had carved out of his, you
know, writings about some imaginary world,
this book Islandia,
which was published and it actually made
it up to I think number three on the
New York Times bestseller list.
And it was rediscovered in the 70s,
which is when I came across it.
Wonderful Guide to kind of the values of,
you know,
living a slower life because it's
all about this guy who's, uh,
you know, his roommate at Harvard
class of ought six, uh, was a, uh,
uh, was from Islandia. And so
he learns to speak Islandia and,
and then when they're trying to
open up the country, he gets tapped.
It becomes the console and he's
sort of struggling with, you know,
the kind of like the modern way of life
versus this. I land in way of life in it.
A lot of people I've tried to
give it to find it too slow. Um,
but what a rich Cornucopia of
wisdom is in that book. Um,
you know, in terms of, of, uh, of, uh,
you know,
classics.
I mean,
you can't do better than Jane Austin.
I mean for an understanding. And,
you know, the, the human soul,
I still remember discovering
pride and prejudice. I think I was
14 and that was a little embarrassed to
be reading what I saw was as a girl book.
Yeah. For sure. But it was like so good.
And, uh, uh, in a similar vein, I,
I've come to love Anthony Trollope,
uh, uh, because he's just, he's like,
let's get this plot stuff out of the way.
I just want to talk about
the people and the ice.
He read a book like the warden that
you kind of go, I'm, oh my God,
I'm reading a novel about the moral
quandaries of an 1850s British cleric and
it's fricking fast.
Uh,
uh, I think of another, uh, uh,
a book when I read, uh, what
was it called? Night train
to Lisbon. And this is not,
I wouldn't say is in
that that same category,
but sometimes it's just a line in
a book. And this was, uh, you know,
that just changed my life in some ways.
It came at a critical juncture and it,
when I was 15,
it was,
and the line was a given that
there is so much in all of us,
what happens to the rest
and yeah,
that kind of moment of cause. And that,
that hit this very deep. Pardon me,
when I was a teenager,
I used to have this fantasy that I
could live multiple lives, you know,
but I didn't want to just
kind of have a different life.
I wanted to have multiple
lives all at the same time.
I want it to be this multiplex person
who could be, you know, be multitudes.
The other thing I would just,
you know, highly recommend,
highly recommend in addition
to fiction is poetry.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
the thing that changed my
life with regard to poetry,
I'm not sure why it was, but, uh,
when I was a junior in high school,
I decided I wanted to get poetry and I
just picked up the collected poems of
William Butler Yeats. And I read
the entire book. It's, you know,
three or 400 pages of poetry. And the
two things that I learned from that,
we want how to read poetry,
you know,
because a lot of people just
are unfamiliar with, you know,
kind of the stylized form.
But more than that,
what I learned was, oh, most of, you know,
20 of them do nothing for me.
And then there's one that just goes bang.
And, um, you know, and so
learning that, you know,
and so many people don't learn
the love poetry because they,
they'd been forced fed 19 poems
and they never got to that 20th.
Paul.
Such a good point. It's such a good
point. I, uh, not to, not interject,
but I resisted poetry for far
longer than I resisted fiction,
which is saying a lot. And then, uh,
interviewed actually a friend of mine,
a Rolf Potts who wrote a
wonderful book called vagabonding,
which I took around the world
for me for 18 months and 2004,
2005 and he suggested a few
starter books for poetry.
And later I ended up
picking up a fantastic, uh,
roomy collection by, I think at Coleman
Barks. I want to say the name is
the introduction alone to that book will
make the hair stand up on your arms if
you have hairy arms, maybe
somewhere else otherwise end. Uh,
I found when I asked a very good
friend of mine has a huge Rumi Fan,
how should I read Ruminy he
said exactly what you just said.
He said you need to read a lot of
them because for me it's every 15th,
every 20th. That just really grabs me
and I know is going to stick with me.
Uh,
so not expecting that you're going to
get or like every single one of them.
Uh, are there any places that you would
suggest people potentially start when it
comes to poetry?
Well, I think you pick up
a good one. I actually, uh,
my exposure to a copier room,
he came through Robert Bly.
I loved Robert Bly is Kabir book. Uh,
what I liked Coleman barks a lot as well.
Uh, does father the Steven
Mitchell additions. Um, but,
uh, you know, you know,
this just good collections of poetry,
you know,
and the poems or the English
language or, um, you know,
I personally, I, you know, maybe it's
too intellectual for most people,
but a Wallace Stevens, go find a
couple of poems of Wallace Stevens.
If you can't read a mere being or
aesthetic demal and come to some like,
oh my God, this magical, then, you know,
uh,
again, he's, he's particularly
difficult because this is a, or an, oh,
actually here,
this is where I would start,
uh,
east coker by ts Eliot. Oh my God.
That, that's one of my favorite poems.
It's about death and rebirth and,
and, and uh, unbelievably good.
Yeah. Tsla, it's hard to go
wrong with. Yeah. So I, I've,
I wanted to come back to living multiple
lives and having multitudes contained
within a single person because I
think you have lived many, many. Yeah.
And My basketball. And, uh, I have
more questions on books and I'll,
I'll just give out a teaser.
We'll come back to this,
but I've heard from a reliable sources
that you love to read old bestsellers
from generations ago that
are now long forgotten.
So I want to find out why we're
going to come back to that.
But since a lot of people listening are
curious about the edge that you often
find. So in 1993, you launched,
uh, the global network navigators. I
understand it. The first web portal,
first site to be supported
by banner ads and
Oh, call me, correct you on
that. Not Beginner banner
ads came two years later. Ah,
okay. The very first ads
were much closer to, um,
yellow page ads. And the reason was that
there were only 200 websites, right?
So we basically were like, hey, we
can put content for you on the web.
So it was close to putting up a website.
Then it was the putting
up a banner banner ad.
It didn't come until the word off websites
that you could point people somewhere
else.
Good point.
That's a very good point.
And the AOL bought it in 95.
Is that right? That's correct. Okay.
Why do you think you were the first
or one of the first to recognize this
opportunity? Uh, meaning
ad supported web portal?
Uh,
well, well, first of all, uh, I, I
should be clear that, um, you know,
I came up with the ad supported
part. Uh, Dale Doherty,
who was one of my key people at
O'Reilly media for many years,
went on to actually start
make magazine and maker faire.
And we spun out that into a separate
company called maker media was the one who
kind of discovered the worldwide web
for us. And it was really following,
you know, earlier threads in our
business. Uh, uh, Dale had been very,
very interested in, um,
online publishing. Yeah.
In 1987,
he had created our first ebook,
which was a hypercard version
of, uh, of a book I had,
I had created called Unix
in a nutshell. And, uh,
so he had been pursuing, uh, you know,
ebooks and we, uh, he'd started something.
Uh, actually I may have the timing
wrong, but I think it's all right.
So we had been basically
trying to figure out how to we,
and we had these books on something
called the x Windows system and we started
working, uh, this,
this is before XML existed with something
called SGML standard generalized
markup language,
which is before the web.
And we were trying to figure out how
to represent our books, you know,
for online publishing.
And there was a piece of pattern
recognition that I had done, which was,
oh, you know, um,
uh,
you know,
the world,
they're starting to be a lot of of
commercial software products for reading
books.
But I felt like we needed a standard of
some kind for our online content because
we weren't going to be a software company,
but we wanted everybody to be
able to read the same content.
This was sort of inspired by,
yeah,
we were a documentation consulting company
and we worked with this guy who had
to maintain 200 different
versions of his software.
And we were like, screw this, you know,
so because we had all these people
who are coming to us because our, our,
our x books had been adopted as the
documentation by a bunch of, you know,
Unix work station companies.
And HP had answer book and you know,
son had info explorer and you
know, so there were like five, six,
seven different kind of, and we said, no,
we want to have one format
that everybody reads.
And so Dale had started working
on developing that format,
which can be called doc book.
And uh,
it was really for representing technical
books in, you know, in a markup language.
But then we realize,
and we,
one of the things that we learn
from the x window system, you know,
this is Bob Scheiffer had kind of
told us this. He said, look, you know,
you know what? We really are the way
that we use free software. You know,
this is a big contrast to, you
know, how, you know, uh, you know,
Linux grew up was simply we're trying
to build a reference implement,
not naming a reference implementation,
a sample implementation
that people can improve on.
And so we had this idea that we
needed a free book browser and date.
I'll discover this tool called Biola,
uh,
which was really the first graphical
web browser and that led into the web.
And then, uh, you know, Dale
introduced me to Tim Berners Lee and,
and Dale was like,
we were just publishing our first book
about the Internet book called the whole
Internet users guide catalog,
which we publish in 1993 and uh,
are actually 92,
fall in 92. And uh, he,
he had a catalog in the back, uh, of, of
Er interesting Internet sites. You know,
if you tell that to this site, you'll get
earthquake information if you, you know,
it was go for the, the web. We
actually, Dale was on, I said,
we got to have the web in here. There
were only 200 websites. And we, you know,
the editor, Mike Luca is actually wrote
a chapter of the last minute right,
for publication. It's so we can
slip it in, but then pay way.
Who was the, he was a student at the
time, that guy had written viola,
you know, uh, uh, I said, well,
I can make a cool demo for the catalog in
the back of the book, you know, and the,
the, the, the catalog was, um,
it was kind of this list of couple of
hundred interesting sites on the Internet
that people could try out. And uh, so
he built this thing and it was, uh,
it was basically a point and click
catalog of the, uh, of the early Internet.
And I said, hey, that's not
a demo. That's a product.
And so our first idea was that
the internet was still very early.
So we, our first idea was we were going
to build a kiosk so people could try the
Internet using this point and click
interface. And so that was what we built.
And then Dale wanted to
deal with a magazine,
kind of like what make magazine became
for the maker Movement about the early
people over the web. And I said, you know,
he originally thought of as a
quarterly magazine. I said, no,
actually I think they all,
I think people are going to have the web
open on there. Uh, you know, there'll be,
there'll be looking at the
way of every day, you know,
so we have to have it constantly updated
and we kind of brainstormed back and
forth and you know, we kind of developed,
so there was the catalog component,
which was part of what we were doing and,
and then kind of articles about the people
behind this, you know, this new thing.
And I was just kind of looking at my
desk one day and then, you know, kind of,
we followed the industry through these
print magazines and, uh, you know,
the way they worked was
there were articles in,
there were ads and there was a
Bingo card in the middle, you know,
which is this card with, you know, kind
of like ms giant matrix of numbers.
Like a multiple choice exam because then
you would circle 82 and the ad or the
article,
you know,
corresponding to number 82 would
send you a package in the mail.
I remember those. And I thought,
that's really inefficient.
We could do that on the web, you know, so,
so we can deliver the
information directly. So, uh,
that was the original vision.
And it's sort of funny.
So the advertising that we invented
for the web was really the,
I was really the website,
the commercial website
because up to that point,
there were no commercial websites,
you know. And so the, the banner ad,
it was this much later layer,
which is simply the idea that you
could build a commercial website that
advertise your product or service
and gave you information about it.
So their first ad we did was effectively
a website for our, our law firm.
You know, uh, you know, within Gnn.
It wasn't because we didn't set
up the entire website, but it was,
it was literally, um, um, you
know, just, here's Hillary,
Roman white McCall. If, here's what we
do, here is how to reach us. And, and uh,
you know, yeah, it was an ad. It was
a, so we had this sort of uh, uh,
directory, you know, cattle.
We had this sort of, hey,
here are all these cool sites and
now here's the commercial catalog.
So, so I wanted to, uh,
just to confirm something about the
whole Internet users guide and catalog.
So this,
this book you mentioned 92 and in a
piece titled the Oracle Silicon Valley,
I think it's just an ink.
Uh, there's a, there's,
there's a description of one of your
marketing approaches and says to market a
general interest book from
a small publisher about a
relatively obscure topic or
Riley devised a novel marketing strategy.
He would turn himself into an activist.
He hired the former director of activism
from the Sierra Club and devised a
campaign that treated the
adoption of the Internet,
like the effort to save the rain forest,
emailed copies of the book to every member
of Congress and then went on a media
tour in New York City in Washington DC.
And then this is a quote from you,
I was saying the Internet is coming.
The Internet is coming. He says, uh,
and O'Reilly media, has the owner had the
only book that could explain it to you?
Is there anything that you would add to
that? Anything you would correct? I just,
it's, it's a, it's a fascinating
story, but that's all I have
as is the case in so many
of these stories. You know,
there's sort of the hero story. It wasn't
my idea to do that. It was this guy,
Brian Irwin. We had
hired Brian Darwin, uh,
from the Sierra Club and yeah, we were
able to hire, we were up in Sebastopol.
He was actually commuting
down to San Francisco. Wow.
This a is a company up here
that might be interesting. Uh,
and then he came in and he said,
you know,
he is the one who taught me about
activism. It wasn't like I had this idea,
it was like,
no,
Brian was this master of activist and
then he invented early Internet marketing
and he's kind of one of the unsung
heroes, you know, he was the one who said,
first of all, he, he, you know,
he, when he said to me is like,
people are not going to care
about our book. You know,
we want to make them care about the
internet. And uh, that was real really.
He taught me about marketing as activism
about big ideas and he was the one who
said, we're going to go do a
press tour about the internet. Uh,
and he also gave way,
you know,
copies of the Internet to people who
are unused that uh, you know, uh,
really kind of pioneered a lot of tea
influence or marketing techniques.
This is 1992. Um, and uh, you
know, he's kind of, it, it's, it's,
it's sort of sad that he has
not gotten enough credit.
I always try to say his name again. Brian
Irwin, how do you spell his last name?
Er Win is in, in, I think he's still,
he left the company around
2000. Uh, and he, he's,
I think he, he's, he's a marketing
consultant still. Uh, and, and, uh,
uh,
living in Santa Rosa.
All right. I'll track them down
and send a link is way, uh,
the,
the observation that you brought up about
the cards in the magazines where you
circle number 82, that's
really inefficient, right?
So this also kind of relates to the how,
how can we make x easier for people?
Uh,
so could you,
these types of questions or
heuristics are interesting to me.
Uh,
and I'd love if you could elaborate a bit.
I actually don't know this name,
I'm embarrassed to say,
but Hal Varian and his observation that
if you want to understand the future,
just look at what rich people do today.
Could you elaborate on that please?
Well, first off, uh, how, uh, you know,
first came into my Ken because he
was the chief economist at Google.
He was the guy who figured out a bunch
of things about the Google ad auction
that made Google such an
economic powerhouse. So, uh,
but it turns out he was also,
he wrote the textbook on microeconomics
that almost every economist learned from,
uh, you know, learn from. So.
MMM.
Uh, but yeah, he, he, he's
made that comment famously,
and I remember talking with him one night,
we was dinner with me and Andy Mcafee and
Erik Brynjolfsson, the office of, of, uh,
the second machine age and machine
platform crowd and, uh, Carl Shapiro,
the guy with whom, how had written
a book called information rule.
So you've been one of panels,
Grad students when he was
teaching at Berkeley. And,
uh,
um,
Carl had just been at the White House
and he was a reacting with horror at the
statement of house, you know,
and it, you know, it's like,
it sounds like, oh my God,
this is the worst silicon valley
libertarian kind of observation.
And it's very easy for people
to react that way to it.
But yet if you think about
it, you know, it's like, Ooh,
first owned automobiles, rich people,
you know, who first owned cell phones,
rich people, you know, rich people used
to fly, uh, you know, or, or not fly.
They would do the grand tour of Europe,
you know,
now soccer hooligans follow their, you
know, their team around Europe, you know,
and, uh, uh, their whole,
you know, uh, you know,
rich people used to eat out, you know,
now everybody eats out, you know,
it's like more people eat
out and then cook, you know.
And so it really is a really interesting
tool for thinking and tool for seeing,
you know, and I think that's kind of
like a such a key concept for me is,
uh,
you know,
people on this kind of goes back to the
structural differential and people kind
of trying to, you know, judge
ideas against other ideas.
Is it some kind of zero sum game?
You know? And it's like, no,
all of these things in a reality is,
uh,
is infinite. You know, reality
is far more than any of the,
the nets we weave to catch it in.
All right? So if you accept that,
then you kind of go, these are simply
tools to help us see. And so I go,
does this help me see? Yes. And so,
for example, in my forthcoming book,
there's a whole chapter that's in some
ways based on this juice, it's called,
why we'll never run out of jobs, you
know, and it's because, you know, uh,
uh, you know, you,
you look at what happens
in rich societies and,
and how basically commodity products get
elaborated in more and more ways. So,
you know,
look,
think about craft beers that are
more expensive than commodity beers.
Think about specialty coffees that are
more, you know, uh, expensive than,
than, uh, commodity coffee. Right?
And what's added in a lot of ways,
it's a story that's added,
you know, and yes, sure,
the story has physical components.
You know, this came from,
this copy is actually address
Alexis madrigals a containers.
Podcasts is fabulous.
This subject.
Then episode four is about
the history of [inaudible].
So the evolution of the coffee,
uh, market, but, you know, yeah,
this coffee came from this particular,
you know,
coffee plantation and Guatemala. Uh,
you know, all the things that, that,
you know, have to come into
place, uh, to make that, you know,
bring that to, you know, uh,
a particular coffee roaster and they
tell that story and as a result of that
story and,
and,
and the reality that goes with the story
that this is actually a unique flavor.
You know, of course, if it doesn't
match, if it doesn't deliver,
then people got not much to the story.
But if it delivers that people, yes,
they will pay more. And so this
is why I believe that, you know,
like as we commoditize labor, there's,
or one of the reasons I should say,
you know, with Ai, with robots, you know,
we can find new things for people to do.
I mean, there's three things.
First of all, again, this
is a major theme of my book,
which we haven't really talked about,
but let's get into it. You know,
one is there's plenty of work to
do for Christ's sake, you know,
so the big question is not,
you know, in know, you know,
we talked too much about jobs and
not enough about work. Because if we,
if we focused on what work needs doing,
then we start to ask what's
keeping us from doing that work?
And we realized that there's something
broken in our economic system that's made
diverting our energy and investment away
from doing the work that needs doing
towards, you know, financial
games, you know, and,
and people who are sort of extracting
money from the economy without actually
getting the work done that we need doing.
So that's one piece.
The second thing is obviously,
you know,
this all this work being
done that, uh, you know,
is not being compensated for now,
I have this sort of metaphoric
can't originally came to
me in the context of, of,
um, open source software. Uh,
but it really can't entered
my consciousness as a
mental tool, uh, in the 70s,
uh, when I read it and in Stewart
brand's coalition quarterly,
I was a concept called
the clothesline paradox,
which is this thing is that simply
disappear from our economic accounting.
You know, so you think about, uh,
uh, and the clothesline paradox,
it really was like, okay, we're
measuring solar energy versus, uh,
in renewables versus fossil fuels.
And if somebody puts their
clothes in the dryer,
it's fossil fuel usage.
But if somebody takes the clothes
and putting them on the line,
it doesn't accrue to the solar
column. Right. And, uh, you know,
and I kind of made an analogy
from that to open source software,
which sort of disappeared
from our economic accounting
for so long before people
like Google and Amazon and figured out
how to build enormous businesses on top
of it. Um, but you know, if you
look at our economy today, you know,
it's like taking care of people.
Yeah. Mostly uncompensated, you know,
a lot of creativity, you know, poorly
compensated. You know, it's like,
why is it, you know, if these things
there are so valuable, don't get paid for,
right. They're, they're,
they're, they're you,
they're taken out of the
economic paradigm. We need to
fix that. And, and you know,
it's not necessarily saying, well,
that must pay for this, you know,
cause the people all supply and demand,
there's all kinds of hacks that
the societies have used, uh,
to value things differently. You know,
just a good example is child labor.
You know, how did we, so we
didn't start, you know, saying,
well we have to pay children more.
No,
we're going to stop using
them for this thing. Right?
And that actually it actually reduced
the workforce that we reduced working
hours. And what did we do with
that? We sent them to school.
Okay.
Right.
We actually paid as a society sent kids
to school and then later we don't need
all these teenagers on the farms
anymore. Oh, let's send them to school.
You know, it was blessed, you know,
and then the high school movement
started around 1909, you know,
9% of Americans went
to high school in 1909.
By 1935 it was about 70%.
You know,
it's like this amazing social revolution,
you know,
so what is it that we could do today
around like, okay, let's actually,
it doesn't have to be that we,
we start paying people could be
that we do universal basic income,
but we some we somehow need to
revalue some of the things, you know,
education, you know, creativity,
caring in our economy. And again, uh,
in that whole creativity economy,
you have to understand that that economy
writ large is wrapped up in that Hal
Varian statement. Because
if you look, you know,
I mentioned coffee and beer, but
just food in general, you know,
2% of our population now, uh, you know,
in the u s works in agriculture,
right?
Yet we have more variety of foods and we
ever had in the day when we all worked
in agriculture, that design pattern
is what we need to be exploring,
you know, to make our economy, you know,
we need to basically say, Oh, you know,
let's figure out what kinds
of things become valuable.
As other thing has become commoditized
and let's start valuing them
appropriately.
Is,
is the decision to value
something appropriately?
What are some of the drivers of
that change? Potentially? I mean,
you have market demand, right?
So there could be, yeah, just a,
for instance you have an Uber or something
like that and all of a sudden this
access potential excess inventory
or idle time of resource x can be,
can be valued differently when people
devalue owning cars for instance. Uh,
you have regulatory rights in the case
of say Cha Child Labor you that you can
change the rules of the game so to speak.
So that the,
the incentives are different. What are,
what are some of the other drivers?
And are there any particular examples
of things that rich people are doing now
that you think are going
to be commonplace? Uh, and,
and much more widely adopted?
Yeah. Well, I mean, the thing
most rich people do that are,
you know,
could become a big driver of
the economy is experiences.
You know what I mean? You know, you were
talking about, uh, you know, high cannon,
it was back to side with Kevin Kelly.
You know,
it's like most people don't get to do
things like that, you know, and uh, yeah.
But just the experience economy
writ large I think is, you know,
and that's everything from new kinds
of food, a new kinds of, you know,
I think we're going to have a lot
in augmented reality. You know,
there's already a lot in media. It's, it's
new kinds of experiences, you know, uh,
you know, new kinds of learning, you
know, I mean, learning is a huge, I mean,
you know, it's like teaching people
to enjoy learning and, uh, uh, uh,
to always be, always be
learning new things. You know,
this is an economy in that.
And, um, the, the, um,
the things that the,
the,
that I think policy wise that we need to
start thinking about is, first of all,
we have a lot of economic policies
that reward nonproductive investment.
What do we mean by non
productive investment?
It's sort of summed up pretty beautifully
in the tail of a Ge where Jeff EML was
in a recently forced out.
I mean, by all, I mean, you
know, Ge, so to say, oh no, no,
he meant to retire. I
don't buy it. You know,
it was basically an activist
investor bought a stake in the firm,
started agitating for, you
know, share buybacks. Right?
And a among other things. I mean, you
know, and the, the thing is so amazing,
they wrote this white paper in 2015
and it describes in detail what a great
company Ge is.
You know,
they have bigger market share than
their competitors and these categories,
they're growing faster, they're
getting more focused, you know,
and it's like this amazing
story of how Ge succeeding in the real
economy and then they go buy this,
you know, but the stock prices lagged,
you know, we must fix the stock price
and the way that, you know, they
should do these various, you know,
things they need to spin this out in.
Some of those things might be rational,
but they should also borrow money.
And you know, basically, you know,
when you buy back shares it tends to,
it reduces the number of shares.
So the earnings per share go up. And, and
think, since stocks are often, you know,
uh, prices, uh, as a multiple of
earnings per share, stock price goes up.
So Ge should borrow $20 billion
to make the stock price go up.
Who benefit from that? Who benefits
from that? Ge doesn't need that.
Ges customers don't need
that investor's benefit. And,
and it turns out that at this point,
85% of all investment in
our economy is of this kind.
It's for the benefit of investors.
You know, we're, uh, um,
Warren Buffet, uh, put it really well in
this quote from, uh, Rhonda [inaudible],
Wonderful Book makers and takers,
which is all about this
other financialization of
the economy. And, uh, it,
uh, you know, he says, you
know, he told her, you know,
sometimes people prefer to go to
the casino, then the restaurant
and, you know, we have built an
economy that is largely a casino.
And this is why,
you know,
I think both Donald Trump and Bernie
Sanders played on this, you know,
and people know there's something wrong,
you know, and, and, and, you know,
our government has basically been
supportive of this paper economy.
And they're wringing their hands.
But this,
this failed idea and this is kind of
brings me back to my book, which it,
you know,
the title of which is WTF what's
the future and why it's up to us.
Yeah. And the why it's up to us is the,
is the, is the key part, because you know,
there's this sense of
technological determinism,
determinism, uh, you know, the,
that I revolt against,
you know,
this idea that technology
inevitably wants to eliminate jobs.
I believe,
you know,
the technology wants to solve new
problems and we have to ask ourselves,
what are the incentives that we've
created in our system. So, uh,
I want the book is really, in some
ways it's, it's a, it's a, an economic,
a polemic wrapped in a business
book wrapped in a memoir.
And a memoir starts with kind
of my experiences, uh, you know,
dealing with and thinking about,
you know,
the great platforms of the
computer industry, you know,
started with Microsoft. Uh,
and what I saw was that Microsoft took
too much of the value for themselves.
Uh, people deserted their ecosystem
and went elsewhere to the Internet.
And then I've watched this
story replay itself as you know,
Google and, uh, you know,
Facebook and Twitter and so on,
have competed with their
developer ecosystem and made
it less of a good place to
be. And, you know,
that lesson seems to be lost. And then
I of course, by extension I've seen, oh,
that's also how our financial markets,
which were originally designed as a,
as sort of an enabling platform
for the economy and for society.
I've ended up trading against society
taking too much of the value for
themselves.
And so it's this sort of ecosystem
view of platforms and, and, and,
and, and, you know, and
actually also in the book,
it's kind of interesting
seeing how I, uh, uh, I,
I hate the books are slower than,
uh, you know, the, the modern media,
because I was kind of saying,
you know,
I kinda call it a little
bit on Lyft versus Uber, you
know, because I say, look,
they are creating more value
for their ecosystem of drivers.
And that really matters in the long
run. And sure enough, I mean, you know,
Lyft is really gaining on Uber because
Uber is extractive business model is sort
of caught up with them.
So as a question for you, I have so
many questions of course, but the uh,
you have, and this is, this is
related I think to what you just said.
So you've built your,
you're somewhat of an anomaly in the
silicon valley area in the sense that you
build a profitable business with several
hundred millions of dollars in revenue
without any venture capital.
This slogan is what
I'd love to touch upon.
We can take this in any
direction you'd like,
but how did you come up with the slogan
and maybe you could give some backstory,
create more value than you capture.
Ah, that's actually Brian Erwin again. Um,
I just want his last gift of the company.
We had a management retreat in
2000 and I think I told the story,
I won't mention the name, but as you
more, more than one answer, I said, yeah,
more than one internet billionaire
has told me that they got started. Uh,
you know, with, you know, their,
their whole business with yeah.
What they learned from an
O'Reilly book. Yeah. And, uh,
Brian laughing, he said, yeah,
that should be our slogan.
We create more value than we capture.
So it came up and it,
of course, we all went, yes. You know,
why is that, uh, that you've
had, as I understand it,
discussions with Eric
Schmidt about don't be evil,
uh, Google slogan. What do you,
what do you think of that slogan?
Is that sufficient?
Is it,
well, the thing that, you know, I,
the problem I have, and, and the, the,
again, I mean, this was a, you know,
we were at Google Zeitgeist and we
had a conversation in the lobby.
It wasn't like we had this profound,
you know, the, uh, you know,
but I was trying to say, look,
don't be evil, isn't measurable,
you know, create more value than
you capture is measurable. And, uh,
you know, and, and it is,
and again, I, you know, I,
I'll expand on this quite
a bit on my book. You know,
the, this idea of, you know,
when you have a system where there's
a platform or an economic system that
creates more value or an RN,
an ecosystem,
this kind of goes back to Frank Herbert
and what I learned from him. Uh,
when you have an ecosystem,
it has to actually create value
for all its participants and,
and you have to be able to measure that.
And we need to actually start
thinking about as a society,
how we measure more holistically
the ecosystem value against created.
Because what we've done is we've created
a set of measures that are focused
exclusively on one set of,
of market participants,
which is really the market owners. You
know, if you think about, you know,
what the stock market is about,
it's about the people who
own the systems to companies.
And we've just, you know, we've sort
of forgotten that, you know, the,
the financial markets are a map of our
expectations of what's supposed to be
happening in the real economy.
And instead we're just kind
of manipulating the map
and, and kind of go, well,
you know, let, you know,
and hoping nobody notices that the real
economy is going to shit, you know,
while we're telling ourselves
this great story. And, and, uh,
I think that the, you know,
figuring out, you know,
are there other measures, you
know, we, uh, you know, uh,
Clay Christiansen's also written about
this, you know, he's, uh, you know, uh,
the author of the, the original,
his original book was, you know,
the capitalist dilemma. Uh, I'm
sorry, not the capitalist dilemma,
the innovator's dilemma, but
he has a, uh, a paper he wrote,
and I believe that maybe a book
now called the capitalist dilemma,
which is really about this question of
we started measuring the wrong things
and, you know, effectively we
started measuring, you know,
a small subset of the things we ought
to be measuring about the health of the
economy.
So what, uh, and maybe
this is related, maybe not.
So feel free to tackle
this in whichever order.
So I guess what I would love to ask is,
what should we measure? But you, uh,
I've,
I've read that you think the financial
markets might well be the first rogue AI.
Uh, it's so if, why, why do you feel
that way and what should we do about it?
And maybe that relates to the
measurement. I Dunno. Yeah.
Yeah. Well, I mean, I
guess the thing that I, uh,
this is sort of an extended
metaphor at the core of the book.
I'm trying to sort of explain
what I learned from platforms.
And so I kind of look at,
for example,
at a Google and the way
they manage search quality.
And you kind of understand that even
though they have this, you know,
Cornucopia of, of algorithms,
including, you know, AI
is all about serving a master
fitness function. You know, the,
the thing that they're trying to optimize
towards in this case is relevance.
Whether it's the relevance of a search
result or the relevance of an ad.
And, uh, you know,
and it's this constant battle against
bad actors against new inch. You know,
you're trying to deal
with new information,
but you're always trying to
optimize towards that goal.
So then I look at Facebook and gang, okay.
So we see that they have, uh, a related,
but somewhat different fitness function.
You know,
Google's fitness function is we serve
you something out and then you go away,
right? Because you, if you've
got the real answer, you,
you went away,
right?
Whereas Facebook's is if we give you the
thing that we really want you to get,
you come back and you spend more time,
right? So it's almost an inverse.
But again, they still have this master
fitness function. There's is, you know,
you could describe it as engagement and,
and I kind of talked through fake
news and how you can see how a fitness
function can lead you astray. And how
mark right now is sort of saying, oh,
wait, you know, the things
we told our computer to do,
our system or not,
what we really meant.
And actually this is a couple of quotes
that I can't believe they've sort of
been life quotes from me.
And I can't believe that I did not
actually put them in the book. Uh,
one of them was, there's a great quote
from Walt Mossberg, uh, uh, you know,
the famous tech journalists to
once said to me years ago, he said,
I told Steve bomber, he said, if you
guys could just dial back to the greed,
only 5%, you know, people
would like you 100% more.
Yeah. And, and, uh, or people
wouldn't hate you. And, and,
and the other one was this,
uh, you know, quote about debugging, uh,
from a guy named Andrew Singer who was
a friend of mine who I hadn't seen for
many, many years. But if
he wants said to me, said,
debugging is the art of finding out
what you really told your computer to do
instead of what you
thought you told it to do.
So in some sense, so
like right now, you know,
mark is trying to debug the,
you know,
the fitness functions of Facebook's
engagement paradigm, you know,
so that be, you know, he's, we're
talking about real communities.
How do we support more real communities
of interest as opposed to these sort of
fake manipulative, you know, communities
that are contributing to polarization.
But when you look at our financial
markets, we have that same challenge.
We have a master fitness function.
You know,
and it's sort of interesting to realize
that the master fitness function that we
had after World War II and
that golden period when, uh,
of the growing middle class
was actually full employment.
They were scared shitless because after
World War One, all those, you know, they,
they'd seen first of all in America,
you know, you had, you know,
all the returning soldiers who were,
you know, you know, homeless, you know,
whatever you, all of this had
led to the Great Depression.
We saw all of this stuff. I mean, it
wasn't just the returning soldiers,
but it was, they went into this period
where people were out of work and, uh,
you know, they see, so
what happened in, you know,
the rise of Nazis in Germany and they
were really focused on putting people to
work, you know, and that was all of the
policy interventions. Where around that.
And then in the, you know, the seventies
and eighties, it really, you know,
we kind of shifted the, the fitness
function to shareholder value and,
and you know, kind of if the, if
it was good for the stock market,
it was good for America. And now we're
kind of looking at it and going, oh,
that didn't work. And you
know, in some sense, you know,
kind of what I'm trying to lay out
the challenge in the book. I'm trying,
you know, there's a lot of
people are saying this, you
know, I mean the economists,
you know, politicians, whatever, I'm
just trying to make the, you know,
another line of argument reasoning
from tech and what we learned from tech
platforms. You know,
the, in a similar way,
we have to look at what are we telling
our economy to optimize for and realizing
that we make choices in that,
you know, the, the economy,
despite all of the ideas of that,
it's a free market.
It isn't at all. It's a design
system and it has all kinds of rules.
Just like Google has all kinds
of rules for, uh, you know,
achieving relevance.
We have all kinds of rules in our economy
that bias it towards the outcomes that
we're optimizing for. Namely
shareholder value. You know,
we have tax preferences around
capital gains versus how we tax labor.
We have rules about whether people can
organize. I mean, you know, you know,
it's no accident that,
you know,
labor got a bigger share of the pie
when labor organizing was supported as
opposed to when it's not, you know, and
a lot of things went wrong with unions,
you know, and, and that has to
be debugged to, uh, you know,
we have to rediscover what it means
for people to be able to stand up to,
you know, the, the, the machines
that we built. Um, you know,
there's no rules about how much people
work, how much time off they get.
And you can see there's
different, you know, like,
just look at German stakeholder
capitalism and go, oh,
here's a different system with different
rules as different outcomes. Uh,
you know, look at, uh, um, you know,
the interventionists, uh, you know,
evolution of the economy and countries
like South Korea and you kind of go, yeah,
this whole free market thing is just,
it's a map and it's not entirely,
it's got some great stuff in it.
It's just not the whole picture. You
know, again, it goes back to Chris Escape.
The map is not the territory.
So we have to constantly check
our map and ask ourselves,
are we optimizing for the right things?
What rules should we be changing in
order to get a closer to the outcome we
really want. And of course we have to
agree on that outcome. But I think we, we,
if we want, if we want a human
centered future, you know,
we can choose that. And again, I
kind of ends, I think, uh, you know,
an optimistic note kind of
looking at the ways that,
that people are choosing
that. And they are, you know,
reaching for that better future, working
on hard problems, you know, doing,
you know,
inventing new forms of creativity that
other people are willing to pay for.
A and building that wonderful fiction
that we have on now we're back to poetry.
You know, Wallace Stevens had
this amazing idea, uh, that, uh,
you know, the reality is, is actually a
fiction that we create for each other.
That boy, yeah, I mean reality in
quotation marks or not. Uh, it seems,
seems to be, certainly seems
to be that case. I, yeah.
Yeah.
His great line is reality is an activity.
It was the most August imagination.
So one thing that I really love about
both reading your work and just speaking
with you is how much the new,
uh,
relates to the very, very old and
vice versa. And what you mean by that,
we're even reminds us to reexamine base
assumptions. So for instance, I mean,
if we look at,
we could look at the fanciest of high
frequency trading or even some disasters
like longterm capital management
to see how these, uh, uh,
systems and humans respond to incentives.
And if you don't look at
them closely enough, the
debugging process can be super,
super painful.
Uh,
or how cryptocurrency has made people
take a closer look if they dig in at what
money actually represents.
And so I wanted to ask you a
question about money and not on a,
on a macroeconomic level, but,
uh, on, on a smaller scale.
And this is a quote, correct me
if I'm getting this wrong, uh,
in this quote, uh, money in a
business is like gas in your car.
You don't want to run out, but you're not
doing a tour of gas stations. I'm sorry.
Yeah. So can you, can
you elaborate on that?
Because there are people certainly
who disagree, right? They would,
or they would not say that life
should be a tour of gas stations,
but they would assert that maybe the
function of business is to generate a
profit and at that as much
profit as is humanly possible.
Can you explain, uh, that position and,
well, I mean, I, and, and
also, sorry, not to interrupt,
but also talk a little bit about,
you know, a lot of very, very,
very wealthy people,
uh,
in tech who have in some cases
come from very meager backgrounds.
I'd love to also hear about the,
the mistakes that you see in your
mind as it comes to personal,
in a personal or familial level
relating to money or dealing with money.
I mean,
my own mistakes.
Uh, no, just, well, I think you,
you appear to have a very
healthy relationship with
this concept of money and
money in general. Uh, but I'm,
I'm wondering what we can come back to
that. Why don't we, where do we start?
I'm asking you like seven
questions in one, but,
well, let me, let me, I guess I would just
say to say a couple of things. One is,
uh,
anybody who thinks that
money is the object,
uh,
you know,
is,
I'm sad for them because money is a tool.
Yeah.
You know what I mean? It,
you know, we want happiness,
we want happiness for ourselves, we want
it for the people we love. And if we're,
you know, great soul, we want
it for everybody, you know,
and we should want it for everybody.
You know, I mean, and you know,
the idea, you know, there is sort of a,
I think a legitimate debate
about the right way to do that.
And so, you know, when, when, you
know, a lot of people, they were like,
we were talking with Russ
Roberts, uh, you know,
who's is a dedicated in a libertarian
free market, or is this kind of,
if you've seen his little film, it's
a wonderful loaf about, you know,
kind of Adam Smith and his book, how Adam
Smith's can change your life. You know,
these are all kind of,
you know,
an encomium to this idea
that there's this magic when,
mmm.
You know, people just pursue their own
aims and it magically produces, uh,
th this wonderful goodness of
the economy. And I, you know,
but those people are not pursuing money,
you know, money is a measure
what they are pursuing.
And so I guess, so that's the
first piece that I would say. And,
and then the, the, you
know, there's sort of,
obviously there's lots and lots of studies
that, you know, above a certain level,
more money doesn't make you
happier, you know, and, um,
you know, the, the, uh, I think that, uh,
you know, in general, uh, you know,
happy and prosperous societies
are more egalitarian, you know,
I mean, not, you know, I, you
know, it's not flat. You know
what I mean? I don't think,
uh, uh, you know, sort of
interesting because a lot of
people kind of go, well, it,
it, it, you know, if people aren't
allowed to become as rich as,
as you know, inhumanly
possible, uh, then the,
you know, your, your, your sort
of somehow cutting off, uh,
this sort of capitalist impulse.
I go, that's not true. I mean,
I just look in my own history.
Yeah.
And I think about the people who
drove the industry, uh, you know,
when I was young and what
their expectations were
about how much money they
would make. You know, and
I think of titans of the
industry, people like, you know,
uh, you know, pupil and Packard or you
know, uh, Gordon Moore and you know,
Andy Grove.
And,
and they probably made less money than
some punk kid who built and sold a
startup that basically vanished
as soon as it was sold.
You know, I mean, we have people who
are billionaires who created very, very,
very little value,
you know,
and yet we have somehow upped our,
um,
you know, uh, you know, so our
standard of, you know, what it means,
it was that great scene in
the, in the, uh, you know, uh,
the social network in the movie, and it
was like $1 million is a cool, you know,
now $1 billion now. That's cool.
It was just like this vanity,
you know, that's, you know,
vanity and I just kind of feel what we,
you know, uh, you know, anyway, I mean,
I guess I would say there's sort of a
social, a set of social issues where,
you know,
self interest should tell you that if
we don't build a more just and equitable
society, you know, this system
is going to fall down. You know,
there are people in North Korea who
are doing very well for themselves.
There are people in Venezuela who are
doing very well for themselves, all right.
But the vast majority of
people are living very badly,
and that's a failed state.
And that's the end game of an
economy in which, you know,
this, this ferocious competition of
some people to get as much as possible.
And, uh, I think, you know,
the goal for all of us should be to
create as much value as possible and to
capture enough of it, but
not all of it. And, um,
you know, and I, I do think
that if you see a, you know,
there's a lot of wonderful,
I mean,
one of the things that I do feel like is
wonderful about silicon valley is there
a lot of people who say,
yeah, that's enough.
I want to go, you know, do
something really valuable. You know,
we've tapped into this with code for
America in the United States digital
service. You know, people who are saying,
okay, I'm going to go to government,
you know, uh, or we see
in, in, uh, uh, you know,
someone like Jeff Hoover at grail
know this is okay. You know,
I'm going to try to develop an early
detection test for cancer. You know,
it's like, I don't need,
you know, to go, you know,
make another startup is going
to make a whole bunch of money.
Maybe he will make a whole bunch of money,
but that's not what he's doing.
Or Elon Musk, what a great example. I
mean, you all put his own money at risk,
you know, you know, a lot of
it, you know, kinda going,
I want to do something really hard.
That's going to really move the
needle about making a better world.
And he's done it again and
again. You know, whether right
or wrong about, you know,
we need to become a multiplanetary
species. I think he's right. Uh,
other people go, oh, we should be
spending their money here on earth.
He's basically, you know, doing something.
He's harnessing this
machine of the economy.
There's a wonderful machine of capital
to do something to do something,
you know, and uh, you know,
it's like he's become rich as a byproduct
of what he's trying to accomplish,
which is exactly what I mean by you're
not doing a tour of gas stations.
Meanwhile, there are people,
you know, like those people
on Wall Street, you know,
leading up to 2000,
they knew they weren't creating value.
They were simply trying to extract it.
They were doing a tour of gas stations.
And I have to say there are
too many people in Silicon
valley who are like that.
You know,
sort of funny because I feel like we,
we call people in Silicon
Valley entrepreneurs and yes,
there are silicon valley entrepreneurs,
but they're also a lot of people
who I think are a lot closer.
If you kind of try to draw the right map,
there were a lot closer to actors
than they are to entrepreneurs.
That is, they're going around looking
for a project to attach themselves to,
which is funded by, you know,
it's like substitute, you know,
venture capitalists for movie studio.
Right.
And you could say, yeah, an actor's
and entrepreneur. Yeah. I mean they're,
they're basically, you know,
they have their, you know,
they're driving their own career,
but they're basically waiting for somebody
to give them money to do this thing,
you know,
and if they don't get the money,
so they really kind of a special
kind of hired employee and uh,
you know, and that's kind of what, what
we're doing with our, our venture firm.
My partner, Bryce Roberts has really
kicked off this thing called indievc,
which is really about how do you
build real businesses, you know? Yeah.
You might need some money to get started,
but mainly you want to get
funded by customers, you know,
because I've see all these people in
Silicon Valley and they basically go from
failed startup to fail, start
off, just like, you know,
an actor goes from one movie to another.
You seem to be so forward looking
and so,
so often at the lead edge
of, uh, various, uh,
trends and changes that become something
seemingly obvious in hindsight.
Right? I mean, you're just, you're, you're
so a forward looking in so many ways.
I promised I would come back to this.
Why do you read old bestsellers
from generations ago?
Well, I mean, really just for fun.
How do you pick them and that if
that's the goal, it has really, again,
one of these pattern recognition things.
I mean, I first became conscious of it.
Uh,
this would be,
must have been maybe
close on 30 years ago.
Uh, I dropped my daughter off at a
doctor's appointment and I was, I was,
I went for a walk while she
was, you know, kind of, uh, uh,
actually maybe I had just gone back to
the car and it was starting to rain.
And I walked by this bookstore that was
going out of business and they had put
all these books out on the street and
it was a box and it started to rain.
And I see it was like a box of Zane grey
books and I still riders of the Purple
Sage. And I thought,
I've heard of that. Yeah.
And I couldn't bear it to see the
books get rained on. So I said,
I'm just going to pick them up,
put in my car and you know,
and I'll give him away
somewhere else later. And I,
but I pulled that book out and I read
it and I loved it, you know, and I,
cause it's, it's this
sort of like, oh my God,
this guy kind of invented the
mythology of the old west, you know.
And I read a bunch of the others and
grade books that were in there. And, uh,
that was kind of, I first started to
go, oh, there's something interesting,
you know, these, yeah, sure.
There's still, they're still
popular in a certain way,
but then they're super dated,
but they're like a time machine into a,
you know,
how people felt, you know, about
the world and, you know, like,
right as the purple sage written in
1915. And I think, you know, and,
um, and, and then, you know, I,
I started realizing the same thing about
other books that I had written, this,
you know, like started to seek
them out, you know, and, and, uh,
uh, a lot of it was, it was helped by the
fact that my, my father and all the time,
he had a big library and I could kind
of read in his library, you know,
and it's like, oh, you know, it's like,
you know, I had all seen, you know,
the Charlie Chan movies. No, he
hasn't. Charlie Chan novel, you know,
by Joseph James Earl biggers,
you know, and I go, let me
read that. And, oh my God,
it's like a time machine. It's like
the casual racism, you know, it's like,
you know, where, you know, people refer to
him as the Chink, you know, you know, and,
and, but more than that was just
this view that the one I read,
I forget what the title was,
but it was, uh, the, uh,
some family from Philadelphia,
the daughter has runaway to San Francisco
and from there to Honolulu and the
view of California,
you know,
distant land, that sort of
kind of the wild, you know,
literally the wild west and then,
you know,
Honolulu off the edge of the earth,
and it's just like this piece of
magic where you kind of, you know,
see into the past. And then, yeah,
as I mentioned to Anthony Trollope,
or are you kind of looking into the
depths of life in the Victorian era or,
or, uh, but what I find that
sort of interesting, uh,
and I,
I started to seek out our books
that are largely forgotten because,
you know, or, or they have some, you
know, some piece of them has survived,
but they haven't survived, you know,
like everybody knows Charles Dickens,
you know. Um, but you know,
only a certain number of people,
yeah, we'll have read, uh,
George Demaria is a trilby.
Right. But almost everybody knows,
uh, uh, maybe not everybody, I'm, I'm
probably showing off too much, uh,
literary,
but yeah,
they've heard about mesmerism and they've
heard about us Bengali, right? Well,
Svengali is a character in George do.
Mara is a book write a
Trilby, which is, and it's,
it's about mesmerism. And the way
mesmerism was this sort of, uh, you know,
hypnotism was,
you know,
this rage through Victorian society,
you know, in the eighties and nineties,
you know, or he was fascinated
by it. And it was just, you
know, it's like, you know,
I guess it'd be a little bit like
reading more and more recently, you know,
Ken Casey's electric koolaid acid test,
you know,
they're kind of Guinness or something,
her Thomas Pynchon, you know,
kind of getting into the, you know,
the, the world of psychic, you know,
Psychedelia and that era of
the seventies. Right. Um,
you know, or for that matter
reading, you know, uh, you know,
there will be a time when somebody could
read Michael LewisLewis' and out wires
poker and it will be a time machine
into this place when, you know,
our financial economy went crazily wrong.
And guess what,
there's actually a novel about that by
Anthony Trollope called the way we live
now about the great railroad
bobbles of the 1860s.
And so, you know, it, it, you
know, in some ways fiction is,
is also a key part of, uh, you know,
a way to learn about history.
And in a way that's a little
deeper because one of the
things that I think we're
not very good at is, um,
you know,
we rewrite history all the time.
So if you read a modern history,
you're reading what we think about it now.
Yeah.
So you could read an old book of history,
but when you read a novel,
you are reading how people thought,
what they were struggling with.
You know, you read a book like a, another
trollop that I love. Can you forgive her?
It's this sort of pro tow feminist novel
about these women who made choices that
were unconventional and who they would
marry and the fact that that was even an
issue, you know? But yeah, we kind
of look back on that, but it's like,
oh my God, you can see it,
you know, as a moral struggle.
And he's kind of trying to set you up
to say yes, you can forgive her. Yeah.
Cause she didn't marry the, the,
the, the socially approved guy.
He's like,
you know,
like it just gives you
a deeper insight into
our own world because,
okay.
One of the things that were in this
kind of brings me back to, you know,
of course ipps gave the
structural differential. The
map is not the territory.
My training with George Simon,
you know,
learning to see our own
world in the same way,
you know, that um, you know,
the things that we take for granted
will,
you know,
we will one day look back on or other
people will look back on and say how
quaint and you know, the,
the, and in our own lives,
our daily lives, you know,
the ability to sort of go,
oh wait,
this way that I have always been may
not be the only way to be that I can
change. So seeing change is, is,
is a prelude to being changed.
So this, this I think is a great
place to, to start to wrap up.
And I have this question I've been
wanting to ask since we started,
but I think that it's more of the answer
will be more impactful now that we've
covered a lot of the context.
What do you do?
You strike me and I think many
people is extremely optimistic,
extremely upbeat.
Uh,
what do you do or what have you done
when you felt down or been going through
periods of a darker times?
Because there,
there are a lot of people who would
like to be change of some type,
but they feel intimidated or depressed
for whether it's personal reasons or
because every time they open the newspaper
it looks like the world is falling
apart in every possible respect.
Uh,
what do you do when you
arch your usual upbeat,
optimistic self if that happens?
Yeah, well, uh, you know,
uh, one, one of the, uh, I,
I sent,
I gave Romaji and the opening to sesame
street and I have to give a little
homage also to the other, a wonderful
teacher of children, Mr. Rogers.
And by the way, it, you know,
before I had kids, I thought,
Mr. Rogers, this is the stupidest
thing ever. Once you have kids,
you go, oh my God, this
guy was a genius. You know,
I'm just, I'm blessed, you
know, to me, I just, he was a
genius anyway. And I, I have,
there's a video of him of him
doing congressional testimony was,
I forget who it was, what was the
reason? It was sort of, I was about Pv,
the early days of PBS.
And you watched this congressman who's
sort of hostile in the beginning,
just so they're gradually just sort of
start nodding and smiling. It's so great.
But I digress.
But the great thing that the,
your question is this fabulous
quote from Fred Rogers, you know,
on his show, he's telling Joe,
when you see bad things happen,
look around for the
people who are helping.
There were always people
helping and you know,
it's just such great life advice,
you know, it's like, you know,
and I just actually just tweeted something
like that the other day, you know, I,
as I had just come
across, uh, you know, uh,
there was a new video about planet
labs. Uh, one of my companies,
I'm an investor in, you know, they're,
they're trying to image the surface
of the earth every day. You know,
they call their, you know,
their satellites, dubs,
they said like all these
military satellites, they
all have, you know, you know,
Dave's a wrap doors and we wanted ours
to signal there for peace. You know,
and this is great piece about their,
you know, their, their launch of,
of the largest, you know, a flock
of earth imaging satellites.
And you know,
I just kind of boasting it with the,
I think the tweak was something like, you
know, if you need your dose of optimism,
uh, you know, you know, watch this video,
you know, because here's somebody who's,
you know, doing something idealistic
maybe was it, I said you do some idealism,
you know,
kind of,
so look for people who are helping
the world be a better place.
Well, Tim, I think you are
one of those people and I,
we could, we could talk for
hours and hours more, but I will,
I think bring this one to a close,
but first so people
can find you elsewhere,
learn more about you and the book and
everything else that you are up to.
Where would you suggest people
find you on the Internet?
Well, probably the best
place right now is a cycle.
Tim Dot [inaudible] dot com so [inaudible]
dot com which is our online learning
platform, which includes, you know,
tens of thousands of ebooks from mostly
on technology and business topics,
but increasingly other things, uh,
but also videos, live training.
It's really the core of our
entire business. Um, but uh,
but Tim's daughter riley.com sort of has
a, instead of my personal archive of,
for example, a link to this podcast
will go on there once it's up.
It also points to my book that will be a
site for the book, but it's not up yet.
The, the, the, the site will be
called [inaudible] e t f economy.com.
And I think the book is, is
something that, it's a, uh, it,
it's really covers a lot of the
topics we talked about today,
but also a lot more, I mean there's
a lot about how do you think,
how to draw a map of your business
model and how to think about the
implications. You, for example,
I spent a lot of time on, okay,
dissecting the business model of
Uber and Lyft and then saying,
what does this teach us about their
story, about self driving cars. You know,
like if you draw a
correct map of the world,
it tells you something about
the future. Uh, and so, uh,
but anyway, so, so you know,
I would say go to Tim dot [inaudible]
dot com and from there you'll,
you'll find everything else
and then on the best place to say hello
and social that be at O'reilly media or
uh, at, at Tim O'reilly, Oily Tan.
I do see all my, my app
messages. Uh, and uh,
also I respond to email and if you
know my name, you can guess my email.
Well, Tim, thank you so
much for taking the time.
This was really fun for me and I have
a reading list as long as my arm,
which I'm prepared to dig
into. Uh, is there anything,
any question or suggestion suggested
action that you would have for people
listening before we completely wrap up?
Well, uh, I guess the, the,
the biggest advice I would have is so
trying to create a daily practice where
you stop thinking and
start listening to nothing
and that they, some people would call
that meditation. Uh, but it could be just,
you know, like when you go, you know,
if you go for a run, uh, don't think,
just let things come into your
head. You know, if you, uh,
you know,
sit by a fire or go sailing,
those are good activities for letting
that happen. Going for a very,
very long walk till all the thoughts
fall away because, you know,
cultivating that,
uh,
that headspace and that soul space where,
you're not filling it up with the stuff
you already have you already know,
but are just, uh, listening is
that, that Morgan's Tarot card,
always remember this,
the space that let stuff come in to
you and surprise you and give you a new
thoughts and, and you know,
give rise to curiosity.
I think that is the perfect place to
wrap up. Tim. Thank you so much again.
I really appreciate you taking the time.
Everybody's check out everything
including your writing on media music.
Great piece on,
uh,
how you separate out fake
news from real news that a,
I think it should be required reading
so much more that we can dig into, uh,
to thank you first and foremost
and to everybody listening,
you can find the show notes, so links
to everything that we've discussed,
including Tim's new book and
everything else in the show notes at
tim.blog/podcast along
with every other episode.
It's just check those
out at tim.blog/podcast
and as always, until next time,
thank you for listening. Hey guys,
this is Tim again. Just a few more
things before you take off. Number one,
this is five bullet Friday.
Do you want to get a short email from me?
Would you enjoy getting a short
email from me every Friday?
That provides a little more soul of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I share
the coolest things I've found or that
I've been pondering over the week.
That could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered.
It could include Gizmos and gadgets
and all sorts of weird shit that I've
somehow dug up in the, uh, the
world of the esoteric as I do.
It could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance.
And it's very short.
It's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend.
So if you want to receive that,
check it out.
Just go to four hour work week.com that's
four hour work week.com all spelled
out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one.
And if you sign up,
I hope you enjoy it.
This episode is brought
to you by zip recruiter.
You may have heard them everywhere.
They're growing like crazy.
They're an innovative platform
for doing several things,
but especially improving
the hiring process,
making it slick and elegant and easy.
One of the hardest parts
of running any business,
growing any business is finding
and hiring the right team.
I've seen this firsthand in close
to a hundred startups. Now, God,
I'm getting old from all over the
world at different stages of growth and
nothing can quite drain your
resources and cost you time and money,
like making mistakes
in hiring ZipRecruiter,
develop their own system and their own
platform for helping you to solve two of
the biggest problems and bottlenecks for
employers posting jobs easily and then
they can get even easier to
find the best candidates.
Unlike other job sites,
ZipRecruiter does an effect the
opposite of what you'd expect.
So they do not depend on
candidates finding you there.
Technology finds the right
candidate for you and in fact,
more than 80% of the jobs posted on
ZipRecruiter return a qualified candidate
based on your criteria that
you select in just 24 hours.
So no more juggling email reviewing
hundreds of unqualified candidates.
I've been there, done
that. Don't recommend it.
We're dealing with calls to the
office, et Cetera. None of that.
Simply screen rate and manage
your candidates all in one
place on Ziprecruiter's
dashboard. And as a listener of
the Tim Ferriss show for that,
ZipRecruiter wants to allow you to start
posting jobs and trying their services
for free.
So if you're thinking of hiring somebody,
you need to find me and my executive
assistant and you'd to find a developer,
whatever it might be,
try out just visit ziprecruiter.com/tim
and you can experience this up.
Just hell used by businesses
on over and over again.
I ended up getting again whole
time fighting for causes dot.
My Buddy Kevin Rose, no to
forever, some of you know,
and he showed up at my gate at my house
a while back and he looked fantastic.
I asked him as said, dude, you look
great. What the hell have you been up to?
Because he's always doing
a weird diet or another,
but it only lasts like a week or two.
So he always regresses to the mean
after like 75 beers. And he said,
I've been doing peloton five days a week.
Now that caught my attention because Kevin
does nothing five days a week and you
know, I love you Kevin, but
it really peaked my curiosity.
Ended up getting a system and it's
become an integral part of my week.
I love it and I really didn't expect to
love it at all because I find cycling
really boring usually.
But peloton is an indoor cycling bike
that brings live studio classes right into
your home.
You don't have to worry about fitting
classes into your schedule or making it to
a studio with some type of cute et cetera.
New classes are added every day and this
includes options led by elite New York
City instructors in your own living room.
You can even livestream studio classes
taught by the world's best instructors or
find your own favorite class on demand.
And in fact Kevin and I rarely do live
classes and you can compete with your
friends, which is also fun. Kevin,
I'm coming after you but we
usually just use classes on demand.
I really like Matt Wilbur's and his iron,
high intensity training sessions
that are shorter, like 20 minutes.
And I think Kevin's favorite is Alex and
everyone seems to have their favorite
instructor or you can select
by music duration and so on.
Each Peloton bike includes a 22 inch HD
touchscreen performance tracking metrics.
I think that along with the real time
leaderboard are the main reasons that this
caught my attention when cycling
never had caught my attention before.
It's really pretty stunning what they've
done with the user interface to keep
your attention.
The belt drive is quiet and it's smaller
than you would expect so it can fit in
a living room or an office.
I actually have it in a large closet,
believe it or not and
it fits with no problem.
So peloton is offering all of you guys,
listeners of the Tim Ferriss show,
a special offer and it is actually special
visit one Peloton that's o n e p e l
o t o n one peloton.com and enter the
code Tim all caps Tim at checkout to
receive $100 off accessories
with your Peloton bike purchase.
Now you might say men accessories.
Wait,
I don't need fancy towels or whatever
other supplemental bits. And pieces.
No,
the shoes you need,
you need the clip in shoes and
those are in the accessory category.
So this a hundred dollars
off is a very legit $100 off.
So if you want to get in your workouts,
if you want a convenient and really way
to do high intensity interval training
or anything else, or are you just want
to get a fantastic gift for someone,
check out Peloton one peloton.com
and enter the code Tim again,
that's o n e p e l o t o n.com and enter
the code Tim at checkout to receive
$100 off any accessories,
including the shoes that
you will want to get.
Check it out one peloton.com code.
Tim.